e
yeah yeah hi all right we it is now 9:30
so let's get started with uh the
Department of Agriculture and um
represent recognize commissioner Jasper
welcome
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee um glad to be here and um we
thought you received this via email
yesterday I know the information was
just handed out um and I'm not sure you
want me to sit here and go through all
of this it might be more productive for
you if we answered questions and and had
a conversation that way but that's
entirely up up to
you sure um just one quick note both um
representative Ms and myself uh have
Bill introductions at 10: so if you see
us run out you know in the middle it's
no no reflection on you I appreciate
that um so yeah why don't um why don't
we just start give us a quick overview
of the major you know sections of your
uh department and then we'll get to our
specific questions about so personnel
and stuff like that yeah so the the
office of the commissioner this is
Michelle tibo who is my Administrative
Assistant directly and there we have an
accountant and that uh and then the
assistant commissioner under the
Commissioner's Office also uh is the
food safety modernization act which is
100% federally funded program with u one
full-time position and two part-time
positions we have um Agricultural
Development which really is promoting
agriculture running the uh New Hampshire
building at the Big E doing the weekly
Market Bulletin and all of our
Publications and handling the grants
that we have um that are primarily
Federal although there are some state
grants when when funded in there and
that division has the director um two
full-time people and a a part-time
person on on grants and oh I I suppose
under my department is also under my
division is also the um person who is
doing our rule
and our um hearing hearings and that is
funded through the fines that that come
in up to a level of 75,000 and that is
um looked at quarterly then we have um
the department of or the division
of uh pesticides
which obviously deals with licensing
those who apply pesticides and uh
registers all the products and there are
approximately I think
12,000 products that are registered in
that fund I think 75% of the the monies
collected there stay within that
dedicated fund and 25% go to the general
fund um and they do an awful lot of
inspections and of course registrations
and they also do all the testing for all
of the uh people working for the various
private companies around around the
state uh and that number I don't have
off the top of my head but that's almost
a yearr round uh operation and testing
because there are so many people that
are coming and going and they do have to
be recertified every five years they
have to do credits and we have to keep
track of all of that um regulatory
Services deals with a variety of things
the maple rules and and Grading Maple
and apples and all of those things um
but primarily their pet food
registration um and animal feed and
there are something like nearly 20,000
different products that are registered
through that
division um and so a lot of activity
there
um then we have weights and measures
which again there's about 20,000
different devices that are licensed
through the uh through the division we
use um agents who are licensed by us
essentially to do go out and do the
actual testing of those devices on an
annual basis that includes everything in
a supermarket Farmers Market um gas
pumps oil
tankers um propane
trucks pretty much anything all the way
Masters the heavy scales and so those
people um all have to be licensed uh
through the state and uh currently the
inspectors there are actually part-time
police officers we're actually having
discussions about removing that
requirement that's getting more and more
difficult to do and we don't actually
arrest anybody um and so with the
certifications that that may be
something we want to look at taking away
we're having discussions with the police
standards and training about that right
now um and 50% of the fees that come in
there go to the general fund and 50%
stay in the product fund animal industry
um unfortunately deals mostly with pet
vending um which is the bane of our
existence and really doesn't have
anything per se to do with agriculture
but that is pretty much where it is and
most most States right now there are
3177 pet vendors
uh oh no excuse me um I think there
areund some 60 some odd the 3177 is the
number of veterinarians are on our new
database system and just in the the last
30 days over 2,000 certificates of
transfers have been made for dogs cats
and ferrets which is a January is a slow
month we expect that number to be uh
probably when all is said and done
somewhere around 60,000 for the for the
year we also do blood testing in cattle
uh and poultry um and deal with a lot of
Animal Welfare issues when asked by the
police to assist them we do not have a
primary uh role in looking at um animal
abuse or any of of those things so we're
there to assist uh plant industry is
actually housed over at Hazen drive and
um they license all the green houses and
really work very hard to try to keep the
invasive species out which we are uh
seeing a lot of times people shipping in
plants that are not supposed to be
coming in but also plants that are
coming in that have invasive species on
them so we're dealing with that um there
uh across the way as some of you may
know we were housed in the U uh State
House Annex but we recently moved uh
last year over to um capital
place and um weights and measures has a
division called Metrology
which certifies all the weighing devices
that can be used now there we're just
back up and running after a long haul as
a matter of fact just the first of the
month we are back up and running but we
couldn't move that for one re for
several reasons but one is that the more
sensitive testing device sits on a block
of cement that goes down 40 ft into the
ground over in the annex so not very
practical and we're lucky there are
states that had to go much deeper to
actually get the stability so 40t I
think is not too bad so there's an
advantage being the granite state yes
yes so I think that's a pretty quick and
basic overview of what we do I'm glad to
answer any questions did we did you
mention Soil Conservation oh I did not
Soil Conservation is administratively
attached to us um and so we sort of
as a as the commissioner I am on the
State Board of conservation which covers
the 10 counties conservation um was set
up in the
1930s and each county has a district
um there is no direct State funding
going into that that's funded through
the Moose plate grants um and counties
also put money in some counties have
full-time people we recently um at a um
uh director for soil conservation which
has been extremely helpful in providing
the the coordination between the
districts and making sure that there is
you know everybody knows what's going on
and um their counties do have equipment
that can be rented out so there's some
coordination there but it's been a very
very helpful to have somebody there
overseeing everything other than having
uh 10 counties sort of out there on
their own and the only time knowing
what's going on is at a quarterly
meeting
so thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
commissioner for coming in how many what
what's your total head count so I
believe right now um we are at 44
full-time positions in in the department
within and then a 45th would be person
who actually works for doit who is
90% um with us now will be 10% with um
um uh well anyhow 90% uh for us so but
he is he is housed with with us and then
we have the two-part time in
um as I said in fsmo part-time in the um
a development and part-time in the um
animal industry dealing with the spay
and neuter
program he heard from uh oh in the
hearings officer part time thank you we
heard from the um Department of
administrative services that they
provide um HR services to some of the
smaller agencies is that the case with
you we yes we had a part-time person for
a while it hadn't been filled and then
we filled it and then it was we realized
that that was really a stepping stone to
full-time employment someplace else and
that's when administrative Services came
up with this idea that we could actually
contract with them for our HR Services
which we have been doing for about three
years now how has that worked that's
working out very very well for us very
pleased to have that available to
us
okay representative
wer thank you welcome
commission I thought I had it on um so I
I detect a longer growing season in my
garden has it helped agriculture at all
we have more profitable Farms are we
increasing Farmers any of those things
that that is such a variable because
you're right it is a longer growing
season the problem is we've had you know
either droughts or the rains and I think
what we're we're going to be seeing is
probably more people doing where they
can more green houses more um of the um
yeah whether they're heated or not but
we've got a in the smaller operations
are going to try to to put in more of
these hoop houses that prevent the
weather from being such variable we
certainly did have a longer growing
season this year I think that Trevor
Hardy from over in Brookdale which is
really the the
largest uh vegetable operation fruit
tree operation they were picking almost
up until Thanksgiving this year yeah
representative
eil thank you thank you for being here
um I uh have a question about your
division of plant industry um especially
about invasive species per se I have a
certain um deep hatred for Japanese
knotweed uh and I just wondered if you
could talk a little bit about that I've
seen in some States they're even
requiring disclosures on real State um
transactions if there's an infestation
with not weed because it's undermining
foundations and is just horrendous so I
mean you can talk about that and
invasives generally and anything you
care to share thank you now Japanese not
weed is one of the things I hate the
most too um and it is something that is
almost impossible to eradicate The Roots
can go down something like 30 feet and
so while you can spray it and you think
you have killed it and you can treat it
it will come back it is illegal to
transport soil in the state of New
Hampshire that has Japanese snot weed in
it um and at this point there is has
been no chemical treatment or even
non-chemical treatment that is
successful because of those Deep Roots
so that's something there's a lot of
research going on it on to see what can
be done but when you think you've killed
that you really haven't I had an area
that actually did an aseptic system on
you know going back over 40 years ago we
had just ignored the fact stuff was
growing on it weren't mowing it the
roots really did it
in once we replaced that there was still
Japanese not with the there I started
mowing that and it took me something
like seven years of mowing it every week
before it started coming up in that area
and I still can't get it get it get rid
of in the areas that I don't mow even
though I spray it with Roundup on a
regular basis well I mean I think it's a
threat to our Agland it's a you know
it's well because it I mean I've seen a
farm they've been trying to get rid of
it and they can't but I guess just in
terms of your program and what you do
generally with invasives I was curious
so if you could describe that and the
funding we just now have the one person
with limited funding for that but he's
more a coordinator we work closely with
do on the invasives along the highway
right aways there's a list in here of
projects we're working working with um
and this is we're working now more with
the towns treat te teaching them how to
deal with them because obviously um
there are some that are easier to get
rid of I worry less about what the
um uh naweed is doing versus the um and
I'm always having a hard time
remembering the vine that gets around
the trees and Bittersweet thank you I
don't know why I can't remember
that yeah and that really is you know
doing a number on our our forests
particularly on the edges of anything it
is much easier to get rid of but still
it's carried the seeds are carried by
birds it's everywhere um and there are a
lot of things out there so we're trying
very much to keep from having this stuff
spread we're never going to get rid of
it in my opinion at least not in my life
time um and so all we can do is work
with the towns to try to keep it
spreading and keep keep things under
control um but yeah it's a real problem
just just so just in terms of the budget
then you have one employee full-time
employee that concerns themselves with
this issue and they're they do some
education and they're also interfacing
with do on treatment and that that's
sort of the summary of that okay thank
you let me ask about you you mentioned
the Big E um is that something that
would be more properly in the department
of travel and tourism I I don't think so
because really what we're we're trying
to do there and has always been done
originally when the building was built
in
1930 um it was an
independent uh commission but the
Department of Agriculture was always
involved and at some point it it became
the the sole responsibility of the
commission
but we we are um working very hard to
get New Hampshire products into that
building for the 17-day fairs some of
our um vendors in there they don't
really do anything else the rest of the
year except build up their inventory of
products for that 17 days so uh it is
very important we try to do as much
agriculture as possible we try to work
with travel and and tourism but um you
know we are geared up for that that is
what we do and that is a good part of
what um a development does um certainly
with our history of running that
building and our relationship with all
of the vendors in there uh and with the
Big E itself I would not recommend that
moving in M as you see there really is
no budget for that because that is
largely self-funded except we have had
real problems with um trying to do
capital projects but there is also a
group in there called uh champions of
New Hampshire Farms they put a lot of
money back into that building um and and
that is working out well and my goal is
to make sure that um there is no drain
on state resources and I'm I'm hopeful
that in moving forward in the future
there are no capital projects for that
budget for that building it should be
self- sustained are you similarly
involved with like the hopkington fair
or Deerfield fair and other similar we
are not the only other real AG event
that we are in embedded in is farm and
farm forest and flowers or whatever it's
called Farm forest and garden so we have
a role in that but again not a direct
budget we just have Personnel who work
in developing that and advertising that
but the fairs are all independent and we
don't have any relationship other than
the fact that I go around every farm and
every fair and give out the
commissioner's award for the best
promotion of agriculture
representative rung thank you Mr chair I
have a few questions um regarding the
Division of Weights and measures so
there's someone that goes around to
calibrate and ensure that the weights
are accurate um are those just for
public facing um places that like
grocery stores places where the public
might rely on that weight for uh
consuming a product any any measuring
device in the state of of New Hampshire
is under our jurisdiction and it goes
beyond just the measuring devices for
instance we're also M um responsible for
making sure that anything such as beer
that is bottled in New Hampshire is
filled with the the right amount and we
have had
investigations uh in that area so
there's a whole different standard there
we're responsible for making sure that
cordwood when somebody is selling a
court of wood it is a CT that's one of
the most difficult things to deal with
because somebody's going to say well I
delivered a cord they must have taken
some of it already it's unless you're
right there and you watch them stack
it's really hard of course patterns
develop with certain certain people and
we can deal with that but um
yeah any anything like candy that's sold
in bulk those scales also have to take
into into account the tear meaning the
candy sticks the wrappers have to be
removed and we deal with that a lot so
uh anytime it is a
um a device that is used to sell
something to somebody then they have to
be you know registered if they're in a
restaurant and saying they're eight
ounces of meat and they're using a scale
there no we don't deal with with those
type of things where the sale is not
directly um okay so like a b a company
that might have a research and
development lab and relies on you know
um scales measure I mean you know uh uh
scales to measure something internally
that wouldn't be subject no but they
could come to us and have those
calibrated if they were concerned about
it so we we can do any scale that anyone
wants to okay thank you and then um Mr
chair I have another question regarding
the
um um oh uh when you spoke about the
division of animal industry have you
been involved or tracking at all the
spread of bird flu Oh constantly that
has been a big timec consuming issue for
for myself and for the uh uh division
I'm constantly I shouldn't say
constantly on a regular basis I am on
calls through um Animal Health on a
national level with USDA with the uh
National Association State Departments
of Agriculture uh as the uh the state
veterinarian is very involved in calls
with um our Department of Health and
Human Services is we're currently um
working with them to collect milk
samples from all the um all the milk
silos if you will from every dairy farm
in the state to make sure that we have
non- detect there um so it is taking up
a lot of our time currently and then uh
just one more question Mr chair um your
activities are really interesting and
they seem like it's really fun thing to
be involved with and I was just
wondering do you have any interface with
schools for student internships where
students might have some experience
working along your fol we we do not um
we have inquiries about that but we're
we try try to uh send people to
Cooperative Extension the University of
New Hampshire for things like that we
really don't have the time or the
Staffing to really do those type of
inter internships I wish we did but that
is just something that we don't have the
ability to do okay excuse me okay thank
you
so I'm going to take the next question
but afterwards it can be representative
mths so um looking at the list of new
positions it looks like you've added
three general fund positions um and uh
two of them are quite expensive the uh
biological scientist in plant industry
and your um assistant
commissioner that is that is correct um
and the one in plan industry is the one
dealing with in space invasive
species um when I became commissioner in
late 2017 it didn't well let me back up
a second when I became commissioner in
late 2017 the outgoing commissioner told
me that the department was in constant
triage mode we were just dealing with
things that really had to be dealt with
and I started looking at the Staffing it
didn't take me long to realize that I
didn't have the B with by myself to um
to deal with all of this and getting an
assistant commissioner became a priority
but over the years in every budget
something else was a higher priority so
I will tell you that even last year just
before Christmas I looked at how many
days had I taken off last year and of
course I had fairs to cover in things I
was a net of eight days that I had been
away from the office other than if I was
at a a directly related at ated
conference um I did take off the 4 days
between Christmas and uh that that week
so I did get up to 12 days off um and
that was typical for the previous seven
years there's just too much work and the
fact is if I was out of the office um
for any a couple of days even at a
conference it was just
almost un unbelievable I'd really gotten
to the point where I said you know what
if I can't get an commissioner assistant
commissioner I really don't want to F do
another term um because it was
just too much um and so that's a very
important position and I I do want to
note to you even though you've looked at
what we've taken from General funds we
are a net positive to the general fund
every single
year we so we have those two funds where
25 and 50% go in and and fines and other
fees for plan industry and all these
places so when you look at what we
actually
spend we always return more money to the
general fund than we take so you know I
think that's an important thing and we I
want to continue to make sure that
happens okay so speaking of that are
there fines and fees that have been flat
for two decades or more you know that
yes there yes there are um and we do
have the
opportunity um and of course this is
with this transition it hasn't been the
uh the best time to be looking at at
that some are in fees some are in in law
and we should be looking at that because
I very much believe that we are a
government that should be um driven by
fees and not taxes um and so in the
pesticides and in the uh regulatory
Services I've had my directors look at
at those and what it's costing us and
what other fees are we do have
opportunity um to increase those fees to
drive more revenue and I will tell you
the one area that we just went live with
this animal database program um which
was years and it takes
$250,000 a year to
maintain I believe there should be a $5
fee for every cert uh certificate that
is entered into the system to pay for
that and when you think of that that's
nothing I don't think there's anybody
who is spending less than $5 a week
feeding the animals and so to have a
one-time fee um would bring us
significant amount of money and if the
60,000 um number is right then there's
$180,000 that we could bring in to pay
for for what we're doing 300 I yeah 300
I'm sorry yes no I had that I had that
300 I'm sorry I don't
yeah my math is usually better than that
Mr chairman so we'll want to know if
there's certain ones of those that can
be in this budget right so yes please
work on that thank we will definitely do
that I'll be
back yes representative Ms thanks um
just two quick follow-ups from some
previous questions um if there if there
ever is a bird flu outbreak in New
Hampshire um does your do you make the
call on whether those birds need need to
be um euthanized the state veterinarian
does and if there is an outbreak they do
have to we have had a couple of small
outbreaks none this year but couple
years back in
rescues where they have birds and
sometimes it's Ducks turkeys whatever
and we have had to go in and we've had
to euthanize the birds in New Hampshire
there is a quarantine Zone um and so all
the bird movement of you know livestock
has to to be uh quarantined for a period
of time in the particular sites that the
birds are destroyed on I think that they
can't bring up birds back on for 90 days
um and that does affect one well there
are two large poultry operations in the
state one is hubard Farms over in
Walpole um and they were affected they
actually probably lost 3 million doll in
sales from their facility there because
of one of these small operations being
in the quarantine Zone um and the other
would be um Pete and Jerry's up in
Monroe they have depopulated their Farm
directly there because they bring in
millions of eggs to process into Monroe
on a regular basis and if they had the
quarantine there if they had bird flu
there they would have to stop um the
distribution of eggs so those are our
our two big concerns are are those two
operations and the state veterinarian as
part of of your department yes okay um
second followup um on the on the fines
and the fees do you have the um do you
have the statutory authority to to
recommend increasing those fees and or
or do do you require legislation some we
would require legislation and certainly
the one I just talked about on the an
animal database would require
legislation couple of ours are in fees
we will be looking at moving forward um
with that and others again we would have
to do through the budget and and or
through legislation so potentially for
the animal database and for the others
um as we move forward we may be asking
for House Bill 2 um amendments to make
that happen because I know that revenues
are very uh very short these
days and uh I think those are
appropriate and some of them have not
been raised in you know 20 years or
so thank you representative evil yeah
thank you so um on the discussion of
Revenue
um maybe I've missed it here but uh I'm
assuming like all the other agencies
you've been asked to reduce your budget
by four or so percent and I wondered uh
what you're proposing to cut and the
direct impacts so my my first priority
was to maintain our Personnel because
we're already you know we're I don't
consider us to be in triage mode but we
do not have an excessive staff there are
a lot of things that the legislature has
asked us to do that we still can't get
to so that 4% um we have funds the cost
of care fund for that goes to um towns
who seiz animals that wasn't happening
because they had to care for them fund's
in pretty good shape so I've reduced
that to an average of about 20
$25,000 in the next BM each year we will
be fine there the one other is the fair
grants program that was started a few
years ago to help with Capital
Improvements again that's that's been
reduced I think that was at
150,000 that's been reduced to 20
25,000 the other was the land
preservation fund um which was being
funded at various levels again that down
to 20
25,000 we will have no new vehicles in
the next bium luckily our Fleet is in
pretty good shape I think we will be
okay with not having any new vehicles
but we normally
replace two or three bium I think that's
about right two or three um are again
we've gotten our it situation in pretty
good shape so we will not be looking at
any um
new laptops computers it's a relatively
minor amount but those were the the
first areas that that we went to um and
so we were able to
to complete the 4% Mission if you will
within that and because of our low
general fund demand the governor did not
ask for any further uh reductions from
us and again you know we are net revenue
state thank you representative leean
thanks Mr chairman uh nice to see you
commissioner see you we heard a week or
so ago House Bill uh
246 which was um let's see the uh
Conservation District resilience grant
program for
$50,000 is there any reason that wasn't
put in your budget or what do you know
about that they're coming in at I yes I
worked very closely with the legislators
and with the districts on that um you
notice I was I was not at the hearing
you weren't at the hearing yeah because
given the reductions we were asked to
make in our budget I could not justify
supporting that I couldn't justify
putting that in my budget as a request
um I I think it's important but to make
those other cuts and to say oh yes but I
think this is a great idea uh I that's
not a message I I wanted to send I'm
hopeful that we might find other ways to
to fund it um I'm not sure that we can
there is another Federal program that
nobody has figured out including the
USDA at this point and I was on a call
yesterday for about an hour on it it's a
crop loss program for 23 and 24 crop
losses we covered most of those in in
New Hampshire it's a 200 million 200
million 220 million program for the
eight for the six New England states and
then Alaska and Hawaii we have no idea
what what's coming in we
requested um these 16 million that we
believe that was the crop loss but we've
covered a lot of that alth we looked at
it as terms of profitability so we
didn't cover all the actual crop loss
because I W in the program I was running
I had no intention of making profitable
Farms more profitable because a lot of
them pivoted we're hoping that we can
use some of these funds for climate
resiliency I'd rather see you know
irrigation projects um drainage projects
because we keep going from one extreme
to the other one year you need a dra you
need drainage and the next year you need
water um more and so we're still unsure
and the FEDS are still unsure what will
be allowed and frankly I wouldn't be
surprised if there was a pause on that
particular program all to Al together
but um it's something you know we have
requested there's a lot more money
that's been
requested even within the other five New
England states than the $220
million so I don't know what's going to
happen but if there was money that would
be available for something like that I
would look to see if we could do
something through that through that
funding source but I'm not sure we could
thank you thank you Mr
chairman yeah I have a question um so do
you think that with the three
new um general fund
positions you will still be a net
positive contributor to yes we've had
those positions in place and we still
are net net positive uh and we'll
continue to do so and as I say I think
if we could get some fees that increased
and one established we could even be
more net positive which is what I like
to
see
yes thank you um you mentioned that
there are a number of things that the
legislature has asked you to do that you
still aren't able to do so I ask you a
two-part question um first part is what
are those second part is which of those
do you think should could some of those
be eliminated or should they be
eliminated so my my thought were a limit
uh essentially to what we do with um
analysis of of feeds and foods that are
registered so there simply isn't enough
funding and time to actually send
everything out to a laboratory to have
those
analyzed we don't always get to do as
many inspections as we'd like
particularly in the area of pet vending
we're having a discussion I the staff
there is is right
now um really Fray and um I'm not sure
that that can be sustained so we're
going although the legislature doesn't
require us to go in and do inspections
on an annual basis for every pet vending
pet vendor we have been doing that we're
frankly we're not going to be able to do
that we're going to have to really do a
sampling of everybody but looking at the
ones who have had
unsuccessful inspections
uh moving forward and there are a number
of those there it can be a very
difficult clientele to to work with um
we uh let's
see so I mean those those I didn't come
up with with a list we were doing um the
uh uh Organic certification we were
spending about 200,000 to bring 15,000
in and there were eight eight other
working within the state so we when we
stopped doing that we started doing one
thing that we hadn't been doing which
was seed
inspections uh we found that New
Hampshire was becoming a Dumping Ground
for expired
seed the total number of fines that we
issued to get their attentions after
giving them warnings and working with
them again we issued over a quarter
million dollars worth of
fines we collected over I think just
about
$100,000 in actual fines after working
with these we found that seeds were
being moved around from store to store
we still didn't get in to everybody we
have other products that we are supposed
to be inspecting but seeds seem to be
the the one that you know if you buy a
bag of grass seed and you put it on your
lawn and it doesn't come up you're
probably going to blame
yourself and that's probably not the
reason your seed hasn't been coming
up yeah so that's an area that we and we
were only able to do with really deal
with some of the big box stores last
year and because they were so difficult
to deal with that took up a huge amount
of time last year so we're we're finding
things that you know we
really had put on the Shelf such as the
um the feed and fertilizer testing and
um we getting back into those areas but
we s simply didn't have the staff to do
representative
Griffin I forgot thank you Mr
chair um and thank you commissioner for
taking my question you're welcome uh I
see that under the uh major accom
accomplishments in survey and mapping
you have
1123 new records for invasive species I
I assume those are separate locations
yes how many invasive species are we
talking
about there are a lot I don't I don't
know that wasn't a question I prepared
myself for but you know there are a few
um obviously the bitter site the
knotweed tree of Heaven are the major
invasive plants that we're dealing with
but there are a lot a lot more um and
then of course on invas yeah that's what
they're covering there and we have a lot
of invas invasive
bugs um we're dealing with and of course
that's pretty much decimated our um our
Elm not our Elm trees but our ash trees
pretty much wiped out in the state of
New Hampshire at this point are we
talking 30 or 50 or 100 um there is a
there is a list probably on on our
website which probably
has somewhere near a 100 thank you there
are a lot that we are not allowing to
come into the state and they continue to
come in yes representative Ron thank you
very much Mr chair um going back to your
comment about the expired seeds and
doing inspections um does your
department do any certification of
vendors or stores that have consistently
met the expectations of your department
that haven't had any violations or do
you do any um communication or put on
your website those vendors who are
violating that because I think the it
would be a public service for people to
know who who's a trusted vendor and who
isn't uh I think that's a good point and
we have had that discussion and this
year we were just trying to get through
um to them without going to that step
but I I think I think there is a is a
lot of Merit in doing that that's not
something that apartment has
historically done and and perhap perhaps
we should and I think we'll have some
more discussion we'll have some
discussions with the Department of
Justice about what they feel comfortable
with us doing because I would very much
like to be able to go out there and said
we've done an inspection of this store
and you know they met all the
requirements
or you know we did an inspection and
they were in violation of of these areas
I think that's something that the
consumers would well be served by but
historically that's not been anything
that we have done yeah follow up Mr
chair um because I I do know there are
some nonprofit groups specifically New
Hampshire Lakes which certifies um lawn
care companies uh so that people can use
their services knowing that they're not
using a fertilizer whatever that may
cause damage to the environment you know
like runoff or something like that that
would hurt a lake so I I would um
support that 100% plus it's giving the
consumer I mean the work you're doing is
really to protect the consumer and it
I think that information would be really
helpful to them thank you thank
you that was a quick hearing yeah it's
it was almost a housekeeping bill so H
any other questions from the committee
representative eil just um from what
you're saying it sounds like the depart
your department was in what I would call
a functionality hole you were really
struggling to keep up with your
responsibilities so the staff changes
really aren't a lot of additives what
they are is it fair to say what you've
done is finally pull the department to a
point where it can perform the functions
that uh it's being asked to perform yes
and that was that was my goal when I
came into
office um and started
getting a handle on things one of the
first things I realized is that we had
38 authorized full-time positions only
32 two of them were filled and none of
them were
advertised and I realized very it took
me a while to realize what was going on
which was we were consistently
overestimating our
revenues and so in order to meet the
lapses we weren't hiring people so the
first thing I did to other than correct
that in the first budget was say okay
well they can impeach me if they'd like
if I don't put in the lapses but we're
going to advertise the positions and so
we got up to full Staffing and then I
was able to identify the shortcomings
the the only area that I identify as a
shortcoming right now is in the area of
the pet vending Maine for instance has
eight full-time people in their pet
vending we don't have anybody dedicated
to that I added one person um to pet to
the animal industry uh early on uh and
that's clearly not enough now that we
are having have a handle when we have
the database and I and I told finance
and everyone at the time that until that
system was up and running I would have
no idea what our actual needs were um
we've only been required for everybody
to be reporting the certificates for
transfer since uh January 7th so I still
don't have a full handle on how many
people are out there who are
transferring animals in excess of the
limit um without a
license uh we're we're going to get a
handle on that um and and we'll see what
our real needs are and then the
legislature can decide whether we want
to change the statute or fund the
department but right now I'll tell you
it is not fair to the individuals in
that in that uh division because they're
not able to do what they're supposed to
impossible so you're talking about
division of animal industry population
yes
course if you could find somebody else
who would like to take pet vending we'd
somebody further questions seeing none
thank you very much commissioner I guess
we'll see you fairly shortly when we get
the house bill one yes yes all right
yeah all right we we'll we'll let's take
a a five minute break or so um I'll go
wer
e
all right I see everybody in their seat
good all right so let's
[Music]
um so let's open the work session on uh
House Bill
246 uh
FNA and um
I guess
let's is there any discussion of this
bill let's start with
that I'm not seeing much all right so so
how about if I recognize uh
representative cells for a motion yes
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion to retain House Bill 246 FNA all
right is there a second I'll second it
second by representative eel all right
if the clerk is ready we any discussion
on this
motion no so just in general I mean we
we still don't know what how much money
we have to fund these kind of things
typically what we do is um if we if we
fund them we make them part of House
Bill too and so that's what I think is
the Committees um has in mind for this
one all right um the clerk can call the
role Mr chairman would you like to go
first or last on the roll call um I
I just have to get something
from oh yes all right before the the uh
vote we have a representative Camal yes
thank you Mr chair uh I just like to
state that uh the motion that I made uh
having said that it's I believe this to
be a worthy worthy effort and a worthy
project and I think that
at this moment it's something that we
need to look at a little bit down the
road once we know we have the funding
thank
you all right now the the clerk left the
room he had to get something he had to
get the paperwork
something
okay so what is all this we have C
does anyone need copies of these
bills you do
here's we've
got okay here's a
197 oh
okay all right I don't think we need too
much all
right representative R thank you um do
we have Mr chair a count of how many
people waited on this like from the blue
sheet from when the hearing was before
the finance
Lehman well there were 12 people that
bill yeah and I seem to remember
maybe there were a lot of duplicate
names on the on the blue sheet and then
maybe two on the blue sheet that were
new something like that yeah
okay anyways uh representative lean can
call the role you said you'd like to go
last and I will go last
yeah representative
cells yes representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
eel
yes I will vote Yes represent muns yes
representative rung yes and
representative Maguire
I think you left off representative Wier
oh I'm sorry I got to write that in
representative Wier
yes yes all
right motion passes motion passes uh n
to nothing
yeah Mr chair do I need to do a um no
for retain there's no report okay thank
you okay all right so let's move on to
House Bill 97
and um I understand that um Miss Rollins
has some uh information for us
about what monies have been spent in
this
area for this coming by any so I did
just
want I did just want to know um in this
the area of Wastewater and State uh
state aid that the uh Dees does budget
what is needed for for the current state
aid um projects that they've have
already have awarded which they did do
in their budget one thing that is a
little bit different this session um
that hasn't occurred in the past is that
hb2 uh last budget there was $15 million
appropriated to this fund for 26 and 27
additionally so that's a little bit
different than what typically occurs
with this bill so I just thought we
should note that there was funds put in
here and then you can decide further if
you want to add a additional funds via
this bill gotcha all right any other
discussion representative Ms then
representative e so I get I I'm I guess
I'm a little confused so there was
there's in in the in hb2 that was
introduced in
23 there was money for the bium that
we're in now plus the B the 2526
bium so there was
the I'll start off with your first
question for hb2 there was money
appropriated outside of that bium which
is a little bit different as you know
than we typically do we typically do
legislature typically appropriates
monies within the current bium so there
was funds put in for the 26 and 27
budget of 15 million for each
year so if this bill were to
pass as is
would that mean we'd have $30 million
allocated to this fund that for this
year that would be correct what I do
think in we could do which I do have a
question out to Dees is get a little bit
of clarification whether that 30 million
if this bill were to pass would be all
for new grants and if that 15 million
that passed in the prior budget for each
bium if that was already for existing
grants
say that all right let's let's have
representative eil and then
representative Wier um thank you Mr
chair this actually is I'm curious
whether someone in the audience can
answer this question um it was my
understanding that the EPA
was talking about issuing a rule that
was going to require uh wastewater
treatment plants to treat the water that
was released after processing I know
there's the process where you have the
sludge and the Wastewater um and at this
point it's my understanding that uh the
waste water that's being released to The
Rivers is being monitored but not
treated for instance for pasas and I
just wondered if you knew anything about
the status of that
rule because it would affect uh
obviously upgrade necessities and things
of that nature for wastewater treatment
yourself hello okay hi everyone my name
is Tracy wood I am the administrator for
the Wastewater engineering Bureau at New
Hampshire
Dees and as far as pasas is concerned in
wastewater treatment facility nip these
permits so that's a point source
discharge to a surface water there are
monitoring requirements for pasas that
is currently in those permits um the
majority of them um the medium
wastewater treatment facility General
permit is about to come out and that'll
include 21 facilities that will now have
those requirements as well so EPA is
adding the requirements as permits are
issued some permits have had the
requirements for quite some time but
they were actually waiting for a method
to be developed to actually test for p
in Wastewater and now that they have a
method EPA sent out a letter in the
fall I think it was the fall summer fall
telling them that you'd have to start
monitoring in
the last quarter state quarter of
calendar year so it was October to
December that they had to start
monitoring in 2024 so we actually just
got our first set of results because
those are due January 15th so they're
just starting to Monitor and the focus
for Wastewater is really on Source
reduction it's it's going to be very
costly and and economically in feasible
to probably treat all Wastewater
effluent for pasas so we really need to
get it at the source and look at also
industrial pre-treatment so Source
reduction industrial
pre-treatment so um
let's H you want to follow up yeah just
really quickly so I well first of all so
what you're saying is we should stop
using it in the products that we're
using absolutely so just
quickly um I just my my question I just
want to be clear on what you're saying
the nipy permits as they're coming out
they're requiring wastewater treatment
plants to monitor but at this point
there's no requirement that the waste
water be treated before release for ass
or what else whatever else cuz I've been
at a couple of conferences where the EPA
was talking about issuing a treatment
rule which would cause a lot of expense
for the plants right well well drinking
water definitely has to be treated you
know because you don't want to be
drinking that um Wastewater is the other
end and they haven't um required
treatment as of yet um the wastewater
treatment
facilities have issues more basic than P
fast they're they're aging um you know
the Clean Water Act was 50 years ago
we've had some communities that have
done really well and kept up and built
new treatment plants we also have a lot
of communities that haven't done that
and are in dire straight now and they're
getting you know permits that are more
stringent they may have Metals limits
they may have nutrients limits and their
existing infrastructure just can't meet
that um we also have what we're seeing
is
is communities that have let their
capacity go you know they could have a
permitted capacity I'm just going to say
like a half a million gallons a day but
over the years they've let that capacity
go for various reasons they could have
had a lagoon facility and they just
decided to close off one of the cells
because they didn't have the Monies to
remove the sledge so now they're looking
at you know they half of the capacity
that they were that they're allow to
discharge are rated for and they're not
there so they're dealing with huge
issues um and past emerging contaminant
is is just one of the issues okay thank
you we we're not really in a public
hearing mode here so it's just to answer
questions if they come up um and
representative wer and then
representative R isn't this money
federal
funds which money the 15 million and the
15 million that are in this bill wasn't
this a Federal grant this is a a state
aid grant Pro it's called the state aid
grant program so the monies are coming
from the state from the state M this is
uh the Returns on loans and so on this
is actually monies provided by the state
from the general funds and it's on
principal and interest payments on
already completed Wastewater
infrastructure projects thank you you're
welcome so this area does have federal
funds and other all these other kind of
things as well as these General funds
they can actually yes well do they have
federal funds in my Bureau we have
What's called the Clean Water srf
program and we get Federal cap grants
each year there's a revolving piece to
that I will just say when we solicited
for projects in
2024 um we had over $650 Million worth
of requests I had about 10% % of that to
give out there's a huge need for our
communities and we just we we can't do
it um and what we do is we're funding
those funds are for the project UPF
front and we're allowed to give so much
subsidy to each Project based on what
the feds allow us to give based on the
cap Grant requirements and so we right
now we have with the bill funding some
different pots of money coming in and
they all have different requirements and
they're all giving about different
amount of subsidy so we take all those
pots of money and we put them make soup
and we decide like how can we give this
money out to communities and in 2024 our
subsidy range from 10% to
35%
so you know on a $2 million project if a
if a community is lucky to get 25%
subsidy that becomes a $15 million
project and what they're looking for is
can we get additional funds because $15
million is still too expensive for them
and so that's where the state aid grant
program comes in interesting so was
representative rung and then represented
month thank you Mr chair um how much is
in the fund
currently the the state aid grant fund
right it's been a complicated funding we
call sag The Saga because it has been
funded intermittently over the years and
I'll I can get to that the the big issue
is is that when
communities put forth a multi-year
multi-million dollar project these
aren't small projects these are Big
projects for communities they have to
put forth a warant article to put before
their their Community to vote on and so
when they do that what they're looking
for at that point in time is a
commitment are there monies there for us
what can we count on and we haven't been
able to tell them that you can count on
sag because it's subject to funding um
and so what they're looking for is to
know that the monies are going to be
there when they make a
commitment in four years and five years
and I think that's the point of the bill
that's put forward is they're putting
forth that they want to see the program
level funded so that it's not only for
maintenance payments but there's going
to be monies there for new
Awards in four to five years so how can
they get that security I'm not sure okay
leave that that's the funding is your is
is
yeah we do have money some money's there
um I can tell about what was
appropriated so you'll hear the 27.9 was
appropriated in the 2023 session that
was hb2 chap
79 and that was for maintenance payments
um and new Awards and
non-lps um we have estimated in 24 and
25 we will use about
21.5 million of that and that we would
have some monies remaining um for new
grants I'm sorry what was the how much
did you say you have remaining we would
and then in this budget what we had Dees
had asked for was 10.2 million and about
9.7 million that was fiscal year 26 and
27 and that was just for maintenance
payments through the end of fiscal year
24 so not including new Awards we're
going to be making this year so maybe
we'll ask the LBA to create us a table
that shows for the the past five or more
years what's how much has come into the
fund how much has been expended to by
the fund and so on right so you know a
kind of accounting of this fund and
what's planned for already in law has
been spent to add to it next year can I
just all right one one more from
represent R okay and and then while
you're here I just want to ask how many
what percentage of wastewater treatment
plants in New Hampshire are tertiary and
um I would say the majority are not
tertiary the majority are
secondary um we have a a handful that
are tertiary they're the the newest
plants that have been built like
Portsmith Pierce island exiter um that
are meeting um the Great Bay total
nitrogen General permit those facilities
that have upgraded um and then what was
your I'm sorry what was your other
question do they all discharge into
Riverway oh the majority of Wastewater
Municipal wastewater treatment plants do
discharge through a nip permit we do
have a few that have groundwater
discharge permits and that's mostly due
to uh where they are in terrain and they
just don't have a river nearby for them
to discharge into so they have to go
into the ground through like a rapid
infiltration
Basin all right representative Ms thank
you um during during the testimony on
this bill I thought I heard that without
this funding being available without
this 15 million being
available um we would not be able to tap
into 600 million of federal funding is
that is that correct that you know that
this is the state match required by the
federal
programs this is not the state match for
the Clean Water srf programs okay this
is the separate state aid grant program
which is the after the fact grant
program where new applications come in
for completed projects but again I want
to reiterate communities are looking
when they put forth a warrant article
and they have a project that's not going
to be completed for 3 to five years that
the monies are going to be there that's
the important piece of this and they're
looking for security that the monies are
going to be there I don't know how you
do that with a bi Anyan budget unless
you appropriate funds that are for new
Awards only and are non lapsing so that
the there's a pot of money there that
they know is there for
them all right representative evil thank
you Mr chair um one thing when you were
discussing the situation and the
condition of many of our wastewater
treatment plants it struck me is you're
that you said some of them are having to
close cell they're losing
capacity um I've heard in my own area
one of the challenges with housing is
infrastructure support and I think we
can draw a pretty straight line
between uh Wastewater and Sewer
capacity um to
housing could you comment on that I I
certainly can there's there's a
huge um it's a direct connection ction
you know and you can't if the if a
wastewater treatment plant doesn't have
capacity you obviously can't add new
connections because they just don't have
capacity we're seeing it in communities
every day where you know we want to put
in Workforce housing but the
infrastructure is not there and it they
want it there immediately and these
projects are not immediate projects it
takes years to plan design and construct
these wastewater treatment plants so
the a stable source of funding for these
projects would be very helpful to propel
them forward knowing that communities
knowing that they have a funding
structure that they can count on will
forward thank you for coming and I'm
going to recognize representative
Campell for a motion
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion to retain House Bill 97 FN I'd
second it second by all right
representative Campbell moves to retain
house bill um 97 and uh seconded by
representative eel um we've had a fair
amount of discussion but I don't see any
more hands uh the clerk can call the
RO thank you Mr chairman on the motion
to retain which is made by cambrell and
seconded by eel representative
cells yes representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative eel yes I will vote Yes
representative muns yes representative
rung yes representative Wier yes and
chairman Maguire yes nine to zero thank
you okay so let's um
uh move on to uh House Bill
197 um I guess we'll why don't I just
start and repres recognize
representative cell for a motion and
then we'll use that as a discussion
Point yes thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion to retain House Bill 197
FN all right I'll second it all right
second it by motion made by
representative cell seconded by
representative eel to retain house bill
197 so uh shall we discuss this I mean
it's it's something I know most of the
members are very familiar with from last
year or the year before that you know
Etc um anyone else anyone like
representative R well as a disclaimer
I'm a co-sponsor on this bill and last
night I spent several hours at a school
district budget committee meeting and
our property taxes are just
unsustainable it's pitting neighbor
against neighbor and when you go back
and look at the history of how we fund
education at the local level prior to
2013 I think when the state contributed
more to the retirement
pension for the most part people could
handle it they could handle most of the
funding come from local property taxes
but it's not that's not true anymore and
we need to provide relief to our our
property tax to our communities and this
is a way of helping out um we've seen
increased costs across the board for
some reason staff expect races every
year um health insurance is an important
compensation to employees and we've seen
just in miramac those premiums went up
they've been going up over
10% um there's so many issues and we
don't want to be a state that drives out
residents from our communities because
they can't afford the prod property tax
so I think anything we can do at the
state to help those
communities um we should we should pass
and that's why I'm in favor of this
bill other
discussion representative
wler we have to um do a tight budget we
have to be able to tell everybody this
is all you can
spend this is a loose end you can't
control what the spending will be you're
just going to commit yourself to
75% and when we took it out of the
budget in 13 it or 12 11 and 12 was
because it was too unpredictable and it
had already gone up considerably in the
previous years don't forget when this
thing was first invented there weren't
that many uh Town employees as they're
every year they're increasing so we
don't know how many towns are going to
add employees that didn't add them
before that are give going to give big
pay raises and this commits us to adding
s half% to all those increases we have
no idea what it will be over these 27
months going forward and the other thing
I point out this is not going to make a
wrinkle in your property taxes you look
back to 2023 we took a hundred million
off of Statewide education property
taxes and send it back to the towns and
said here's a big reduction in the
property tax it should have amounted to
a couple hundred dollars per per uh
taxpayer if there's 500 th000
taxpayers nobody even saw it it got
together with people do you see a tax
decrease in 2023 no no no what
happened this would not make a bit of
difference in property taxes what we've
got to do is control School spending if
we're worried about property taxes not
this contribution this is this is not a
good idea because it's a loose end thank
you others representative mths thank you
Mr chairman um I um I I I agree with
everything that representative rung said
and and and the only thing that I would
add is we heard during testimony that um
uh from from representative Mark bone
from eping that if this were to this
were to pass it would um provide
$780,000 to the eping school district
which would allow them then to pay the
full cost of the contract that they are
considering for their teach
without having to increase property
taxes so it will have an impact a
positive impact on um on on
municipalities and school districts and
um you know for all the reasons that
representative rung mentioned I uh I
also believe that we need to move
forward with
this thank you others no okay um I'll
just throw my own two cents
in to me one of the worst aspects of of
government funding
structure is the the way we say to
people if you spend a dollar I'll give
you 20% right I I'll give you 20 cents
that kind of thing right that's just an
incentive to spend more than you would
otherwise right it's just like when you
when you go to buy go to the store and
you buy something on sale right they
they say you know uh you buy a chicken
25% off well guess what that cause
causes a lot more sales of chicken than
it would otherwise same thing here if we
say to somebody if you spend X I'll give
you some percentage of it and the
federal government does this all the
time it's just an incentive to spend
more now the way the right way in my
opinion to subsidize is more like what
we do with adequate education if you
have a kid we give you X doll right
there's no nobody can change what sort
of kids they have they either have them
or they don't right and so it's not an
incentive to somehow spend more it's an
incentive it's it's a it's an assist on
what they do spend right so that's the
right way to subsidize this in my
opinion is the wrong way so all right so
I guess we we're missing one person but
I go yeah okay to a hearing
representative leean yes uh just kind of
a followup Mr chairman I think it's
important to point out that we're facing
what could be a $500 million deficit and
this bill alone in the first year cost
28 million so it would be a concern of
mine carrying this forward with knowing
that we have such a huge deficit to face
but absolutely all right um if I there's
no further discussion the clerk can call
thank you Mr chairman on the motion on
House Bill 197 to retain made by
cambrell seconded by eel representative
cells
yes representative Griffin
yes representative Sweeney
yes representative eel yes I'll vot yes
representative Ms is absent
representative rang yes and
representative
Wier representative Maguire yes a to
zero if only all our votes are unanimous
be very happy that's our plan is it all
right so let's talk for a moment before
we break up on
scheduling um so uh here's our plans for
what what's going forward we're getting
into the busy season so we're going to
hear the governor's budget address on
February 13th the that's a Thursday in
house session and then she'll be coming
to house finance the next day
Valentine's Day in the afternoon so
we'll we'll have a couple hours with her
to to talk about the details of the
budget and so um then the following
Monday is a
holiday and um our general plan for this
division is to basically have Tuesdays
off because I'm um with represent of
Earth and papa Mller we uh I'm on the
uh education funding committee so we're
going to dedicate Tuesdays to that so
this committee will meet essentially
from that point
forward
um Wednesday any Thursday that's
available that's not a house session day
Friday and and then and Mondays so um so
that week the we'll meet here here on
Wednesday the 20th I think it is um the
19th is it the 19th it's the 19th okay
so we'll meet Wednesday the 19th we'll
meet uh Friday the 21st because I think
uh Thursday is a house session day right
and then the following week we'll meet
uh uh Monday Wednesday Thursday Friday
because that Thursday is not a house
session day but Monday
no Monday we're not meeting Tuesday
right so we'll meet Monday Wednesday
Thursday Friday as a division so that's
six days left in this month to meet
right and on
21st oh I see okay um is that you
typically have it in this room is
that oh in the big room so maybe we miss
you for that is that oh oh there's too
many yeah yeah yeah okay
and Jerry okay so we can't meet then so
is fiscal just the morning is that
generally start proba
preis
okay so maybe we can meet at 1:15 is
that is that okay yeah all right so so
so we'll have five and a half days it
sounds like left in this month
um to kind of we're going to get into
house bill one for all of our agencies
right so um and uh go through all the
line by line stuff and and um there may
be a little of that left over it sounds
like into March but then we'll get into
House Bill 2 sections in March and any
further bills that we may have um are
you planning any full committee hearings
okay
okay okay so can
we but are you planning any full
committee public I guess we everything
we got now is second committee right so
unfortunately I have one bill that
hasn't had a car late I'm sorry Mr chair
so we're going to have to have a full
Committee hearing
will that be March or that you're going
to try to do that in February most of
the deadlines we have on bills
March inch okay so so the first week of
March maybe we'll finish up that your
bill um and maybe there's some others
you know have a full Committee hearing
that week um we'll finish up any house
bill one stuff we have and then start
getting into um how Bill too but just in
general I'll try not to schedule any
division one stuff on Tuesdays so
that'll be our day off okay any comments
representative leean thanks Mr chairman
so you know from our past experience
that we generally need almost every day
of the week to get through the budget
and why is Tuesday a complete day off I
guess I missed that so that's because
I'm assigned to the I and and
representative Earth and papa Mohler
have been assigned to the education
funding committee so that's the one day
that they're going to said Wednesday or
something too but no just Tuesday just
Tuesday right and that so anytime
they're going to have an exact session
it'll be a
Tuesday right so that's that's kind of
what we're doing they're actually going
to meet they've been meeting we've been
meeting um Tuesday and
Friday but I'm going to have to move
move Fridays to here right so is there
any reason we couldn't have
representative cambrell Serv as chair un
those Tuesdays and not make a decision
unless you're here or I just just
knowing about the future of this we are
like so book solid for four to five
weeks so we have to be here every day in
order to get through the budget and
having a complete day off like Tuesday
could be you know could be a problem
I mean it's been done before yeah yeah
yeah and that's where we're meeting five
days a week you know so all right well
why don't we try it for
February and then see how it goes okay
because I have complete faith in
representative cambrell I
understand representative evil I mean
isn't it isn't it true that a lot of the
Ed funding bills are first committee
bills that are then subsequently coming
to so Finance I mean do you think that
your uh agenda there or schedule there
will lighten up a little
bit absolutely yes so so the deadline
for early bills is March
6th right so I do think that Tuesday the
first Tuesday in March probably will be
a lot of exact stuff over there so
things might lighten up for you then a
little yes yes yeah right exactly so I
may not have to be there at all after
March 6th right or next to anyway that's
crunch time yes exactly it is okay so
that's our current plan we'll we'll
figure it out so so plan to be
here uh essentially every day after
starting on the
13th except for Tuesdays okay all right
all right and we'll see you at 1:15
today
e
all right it is now 1:15 and we'd like
to welcome uh commissioner Hanks from
the Department of Corrections thank you
for
coming good afternoon honorable members
of the house finance for the my name is
Helen Hanks I'm the commissioner of the
Department of Corrections with me to my
left is Lisa Stone our director of
administrative services and happy to
spend some time doing an overview with
you this afternoon um and as always as
we go through the presentation if
there's information that we've not
provided that you'd like we will take
note of that and make sure we get it to
the committee I think we sent you some
special questions yeah you certainly did
and they're included in this packet
you're
welcome I always think it's important uh
you'll see at the beginning of my
presentation on two and three to reenter
on what the statutory obligations are of
the department and include our mission
vision and core values I know you'll
read
those on page four is a highlevel
organizational chart um then we go into
page five we have a total of three
Correctional Facilities one secure
psychiatric unit that also has a
residential treatment unit we have one
transitional work center uh out of a
security secure perimeter for the men
the transitional work Center for Women
is within the secure perimeter of the
New Hampshire correctional facility for
women and we continue to have three
transitional housing units one in
Manchester for men uh two in conquered
one for men and one for women for the
main three could you give us the
capacity I believe those are on the
chart you want the this is the current
population if you want the capacity the
design capacity I'll get that to you yep
happy to
uh on page seven I think it's important
to share what the current resident
population data demonstrates the uh
total in custody is
1,925 as of January 1 2025 obviously
that number fluctuates we continue to
have uh other individuals has at a state
for multiple security reasons that
numberers range anywhere from the number
you're seeing here 166 to as high as 200
it hasn't fluctuated significantly in
the time that I've been with the
Department
we've included the minimum sentence
structure uh by sentence length and
maximum sentence structure by sentence
length I always like to point out that's
for the sentences they're serving at the
time of the report uh this data can't
take into consideration con uh
consecutive sentences when we look at it
so there is some marginal difference uh
what we will and I will tell you the
minimum and maximum sentences are rising
through the course of my time in 20
years it used to be an average of three
and a half to 7 it's now closer to 5 to
10 uh I think that uh is easily
explained in the types of offenses that
people are being incarcerated for and
it's because we have a higher number of
individuals who are incarcerated for uh
crimes such as aggravated fonia seexual
assault and fonia sexual assault and so
they are accordingly uh receiving higher
sentences on page eight start to show
you uh more demographics by age uh
self-reported race and uh very high
type as you can see crimes against
person is the highest
rate and those include again the crimes
I just mentioned and other more
significant
crimes on page nine uh showing you a
trend of population by month U and then
it includes Admissions and what we call
releases or bookings and releases the
average number of releases is decreasing
which means we are booking about the
same number of people into incarceration
a month but we're not releasing uh the
same number so our population is
climbing a little bit um I have an audit
occurring just to understand the root of
that uh change and so when I get that
information I'll certainly share that
with the committee because I think it
helps us understand the populations
we're managing New Hampshire in
comparison to other states we're not
seeing what other states are
experiencing other states are
experiencing significant rises in
incarcerated populations ours is is a
bit static which is good um so we're
balanced from that
perspective um and then I have gender
breakdowns on that page as well we
continue to have a much smaller number
of women incarcerated at the state
correction system than
men on page 10 I'll move on and I'm very
proud of what this organization has done
because part of the balance of providing
Safety and Security is also providing
treatment and Rehabilitation and of
course we want to reduce reincarceration
when that's appropriate when I took uh
the lead of the organization in
2018 to date we've reduced our uh
recidivism rate from 48% to down uh to
approximately 40% so that's an 8%
decrease in people returning to
incarceration and try to give you
literally a road map of the things that
we've implemented over time uh about how
that on page 11 uh one of the challenges
I adopted when I took over as
commissioner was uh the case loads uh in
our probation and parole service were
incredibly High um I spent a lot of time
uh trying to adjust that uh the national
uh standard is 1 to 50 in an average
case load and 1 to 35 when it's a
specialty case load uh so I'm trying to
actually show you the proportion of
people on probation and parole the
number of officers we have the types of
supervision and where they're located on
page
11 and then I have more detail for you
on page 12 where I give you the actual
addresses and supervision case load of
those probation appro offices associated
with our Field Services
Division could you explain that you said
it's 50 per officer m is that right and
and where would I see what we're
actually doing on page 13 sir headed
right there story
continues um so again uh talking about
uh when I took over an fy17 at the top
of the page reading right to left so
left being current right being the
longest time ago we averaged about 1 to
94 we're now about 1 to 54 and some of
that is uh literally repurposing other
law enforcement positions and creating
new probation parole officers to help
equalize those specialty case loads um
and then to our benefit we've also seen
a reduction in people on probation and
parole in the state so we've had a
two-pronged effort and try to bring that
forward um the other uh implications uh
was looking at our Fleet Management and
field services when I came on they had
19 Vehicles we through the state process
have increased that to 25 our first
Target was to take any office that had
one vehicle and get them a second
vehicle so they could do those infield
visits and now we're leaning in uh to
our larger case load offices and looking
to see if we can deploy more resources
to help them be in the field and I I see
representative muns has a question yes
representative muns thank you Mr chair
thank you for U taking my question um
the uh the reduction in case loads is is
very impressive um can but can you can
you give me any sense as to what the
kind of industry best practice is in
terms of what case loads should be
certainly uh again the industry standard
nationally is 1 to 50 if it's a
35 yeah meaning drug cord or something
like that meaning drug Court sir or
veterans court or mental health court
those those tend to be wanting down to 1
to 35 so is this because uh people are
spending less time on probation and
getting off sooner or what's why is this
big reduction yeah there's a the hampire
should be proud we're ranked number one
both in safety and Corrections and
that's because our crime rate is
decreased uh versus other states cross
the country and our population has
decreased so some of it is all of the
effort for the last decade the states
invested in both specialty courts and
other diversion activities are um just
individuals are not committing as many
crimes um and we're really looking at
things on the reintegration or reducing
recidivism side to make these things um
really balanced it takes everyone's
effort in the justice system in the
community mental health system uh in the
housing uh area to really start to
effectuate this change in our
state so are you're saying these are not
these 4,000 people are not ones that
served three years and now they're out
on probation as much as people who are
sentenced to probation is that right or
both some of both they're both yep so
the 4,025 is a combination of both
probation and parole on uh page 11 I
break out the probation and parole cases
for you by men and women so if you look
at this chart
here you'll see them broken
out yes representative evil could you
clarify for us the difference between
probation and parole happy to do that
probation is a court ordered supervision
time you serve on probation is time you
serve on probation parole however is
after you've served a sentence of
incarceration you go before the adult
parole board and you can then be granted
the privilege of parole which is
supervision after you've served that
minimum sentence time served on parole
is time serves toward your total
sentence so that time is served towards
that maximum sentence as well I hope
that clarifies pration is generally
ordered in an attempt to divert from
incarceration give you a chance to
demonstrate compliance with Community
standards if you violate probation you
can then be uh rendered a sentence of
incarceration from that sentencing judge
okay thank you you're welcome so what
seems weird to me is incarceration is
relatively flat but this number is
dramatically lower and and so you're
saying it's because there's less crime
right but saying that's one element but
the crime that there is is increasingly
violent maybe or something like that is
that why that's why both numbers are not
going down in a similar way is that it's
also sir because the parole violation
rate so when you look at that total uh
case load of
parole if just 10% of that results in a
parole violation those are I'll call
them incarcerated
days and so those incarcerated days are
the ones we're trying to shrink because
if we can shrink those parole violations
through supported Community Action then
we can reduce the number of people who
are actually incarcerated so the new
sentence new incarcerated sentence
bookings that happen in New Hampshire
those are continue to be relatively
static so that crime rate but it is the
conduct while on parole and granted
again comparison to the the case load
it's a small number of people but that
small number of people utilize a high
amount of incarcerated stays so we
really trying to focus in on that data
element we worked a lot and actually in
hindsight if I haven't I will make sure
we send out to this committee with the
council state governments who did a
two-prong study of high utilizer of our
jail service in the state and then
mapped to prison service and looked at
our Medicaid service
and to try to narrow in and say where
are we where are where's the most need
or the most intervention to reduce the
cost of the state and the justice system
and I think that will help inform this
committee a lot and it centers on those
individuals returning to incarceration
from parole violations uh and the top
three reasons their parole is violated
is for re-engagement in criminal conduct
substance use or substance use disorder
and lack of compliance with treatment
and that that three-pronged combination
is where we're really focusing our
resources you're welcome EV so then um
the reason that it's better to have more
parole officers with smaller case loads
is that you can support the Parolees
better with the hope of having them not
be reincarceration would that be
correct represent there's actually
there's lots of studies that try to
answer that question okay um and I and
they they're really inconclusive but the
idea of the specialty courts and I I'll
narrow in there because that's important
is we've already pre-identified people
are high risk in those specialty courts
and having that really supervision to
treatment compliance is the part where
we've really demonstrated efficacy that
it helps reduce people to continue into
the justice system uh that's where we
want to get to that 1 to 35 and the 1 to
50 is literally to make sure people are
compliant with their parole plan and
it's had it's hard to ask a person to
manage a hundred people at different
risk levels so we also assess their risk
and on page uh 11 I try to give you uh
the examples of those levels of
supervision in the in the bottom right
corner because if we have a high-risk
person we're going to spend more time
checking in on you and we literally have
to have enough probation parole officers
to meet those
obligations and and incarceration is the
most expensive of all the absolutely yes
y okay and so when the Judiciary tells
us that drug court is working well this
is sort of where we see the number that
proves it right is that the idea all
see it's it's also sir when I uh come
and testify that we need more probation
appr officers that more you ad specialty
courts yeah thank
you uh so then on uh page 14
uh making sure we show you our funding
sources uh this committee knows well we
are primarily uh General funds we have a
small portion of federal funds we
utilized arpa funds and then we have
these other funds and we try to explain
those uh underneath our Correctional
Industries some uh grants associated
with VCA uh vocational training trust
dollars um and miscellaneous items such
as
that just paused see if you have any
questions
there um so what's the other funds would
be from where yeah underneath uh our
Correctional Industries program so the
sign shop and those uh elements I see
yeah furniture and exactly those things
representative Ms thank you Mr
chair I'm I'm new to this committee so
there may be stuff going on here that I
not not not aware not aware of but the
first thing that jumps out of me on this
chart p on page 14 is how do you
possibly do in fiscal 26 what you did in
fiscal
25 with so less with so much less
money uh part of that major shift is no
longer needing those arpa dollars so
that's a a major shift there um and then
when we navigate to the other Pages I'm
I'm going to explain a little bit of
some of the strategy that we're
proposing around our overtime funding so
very intuitive question
sir so as we flip to the next page on
page
15 what you can see uh and what we've
done on purpose is broken out our
general funds and you can see the
percent of those uh funds by each fiscal
year across the total
allocation so when you look at the
difference that representative Ms just
asked um and as I I have to try to
remember where I testified about this
the last time so forgive me sir uh and
members of the committee when you look
at our overtime line we had historically
uh put monies in that overtime line uh
if you look at fy2 there are $7.4
million there in uh 26 and 27 we've put
$2,100 hence why those bar graphs look
very different it is not because this
department depart doesn't think we're
going to need overtime funding but on
the following page what we're suggesting
is to continue to allow us to use the
foot note you've provided in the past
where we take funding from our vacant
positions and benefits and salaries and
move those into overtime and then if
those funds do not fill the void then we
would come back before fiscal and ask
for additional
Appropriations um so it's a two-pronged
effort to use both the vacant and
benefit lines as we've done in the ped
and that has been successful to fill for
overtime that has resulted from those
vacancies but in the absence of existing
funds in the fiscal year and that
strategy working that we would go before
fiscal to ask for additional
overtime so all right let me ask first
so the permanent line then includes a
lot of unfunded positions or not they're
all funded I mean un unfilled positions
yes so we currently have a for example a
42% vacancy rate in our law enforcement
ranks which is significantly better uh
than it was uh six plus months ago so
we're moving in the right direction but
we would then move those lines in in the
absence of filled positions into the
overtime line so why is this Superior to
Simply budgeting more like what you
think is going to happen namely that
most of those positions are going to
stay un unfilled and more overtime will
happen well we're hopeful that we move
in a better trend line which we have
been doing and U cognizant of the
state's current uh financial situation
so we didn't want to ask for money that
we really couldn't necessarily forecast
but if as we travel through the
budgeting process the house and the
Senate want to put line or funding in
our overtime line we would not be uh
yeah I I think you probably already
answered this but if the way I'm reading
this is um the FY 26 efficiency
expenditure request what you're saying
is that if all of the positions are
filled then you'll for permanent for
example you'll you'll need 71,1
174,000 and virtually no overtime it it
but if those if those positions aren't
all filled then that $71 Million number
is going to come down and it's going to
okay okay thank you and then so then as
we navigate through uh other areas where
the department affects the general fund
it's been traditionally in our
prescription drugs and our medical
payments to Providers and we've um taken
a lot of effort in trying to reduce
those costs in prescription drugs as
well as medical payments to Providers
are especially Community Based uh
payments so we're embarking on a new
initiative uh utilizing a centers for
medicated Medicare Services 1115a
re-entry waiver and the state was
granted that waiver and it started on
January 1st and our first cohort of
individuals will be eligible to
participate in the middle of this month
so what is that waiver it provides 45
days for people prior to release
Medicaid coverage and two provider
encounters and two peer-to-peer
encounters as as well as 30 days of
medications upon release and then all of
the other managed care benefits of
helping a person who's released from
incarceration navigate continued Health
Care coverage so when I talked about
those three pronged efforts of people
returning to incarceration this is our
goal to continue to stabilize that
transition of treatment to community and
have some of those costs uh covered
under Medicaid especially the discharge
medications we also continue on the
pharmaceutical line to have our 340b
partnership with health and human
services so we have a lot of discounted
Pharmaceuticals around the treatment of
sexually transmitted infections and
hepatitis C we continue to have funding
under the state opioid response dollars
to help provide uh pharmaceutical
payments for treatment of medication for
opioid use disorder and I apologize that
acronym changes so many times so I'm
just going to use the one I know
today uh and then we also continue to
have our pharmaceutical and Therapeutics
committee where our chief pharmacist
meets with the providers and talks about
the trending right now we're getting an
incredible uh reduced rate on the
treatment of medications for opio use
disorder and we just really navigate
this on a monthly basis to see what we
can do to really maximize the the
efficiency of our purchasing and make it
cost effective while we also deliver the
appropriate treatment during
incarceration on the Medicaid payments
to Providers um I think some of the work
that we're doing again with that 1115 a
waiver complements what we're trying to
accomplish um as well as talking about
some of what we see uh with regards to
inpatient stays and making sure those
eligible inpatient stays during Inc
incarceration are remitted for Medicaid
payment rather than general fund payment
I think there's some opportunity for
conversation around how those claims are
coded um there are things called
Observation stays we as Citizens when we
go to the hospital there's an
observation stay and if that observation
stay is coded by a provider that way and
it's 7 days it's still an observation
stay those are not eligible for payment
under impatient paent in Medicaid um so
we're really looking at those
opportunities to Advocate both at the
federal level within the state
opportunities of whatever in law to help
us really narrow how that happens
because it affects this line in the
general fund and how we can really use
different opportunities to pay for
health care for people incarcerated in
New
Hampshire um we go out for
representative evil um could you I mean
I assume when you're in a Corrections
Facility the facility is respond
responsible for your medical care pretty
much like so what happens if there are
Cuts in Medicaid or you know from the
federal government I mean at the state's
going to have to pick it up or how do
you see that playing out if you had less
Medicaid Finance opportunity let's put
it that way y so right now represent
aable about $2 million is deferred to
the Medicaid budget and the rest of the
cost is borne by the state through
general fund so that $2 million would be
affected in some way and the state would
would bear that cost so when you look at
a total of potentially $13 million that
doesn't even represent the 2 million
that we've deferred so we basically
could have a $2 million liability if the
federal government doesn't give us that
Medicaid
coverage I hope that answers your
question is the reason that um fiscal
year 27 is lower than 26 is because you
assume you're going to sort of get
better at uh moving things off onto
Medicaid than you are today is that kind
of it is representative McGuire and it's
also our hope that we continue to reduce
the reincarceration rate so really
tackling reducing that reincarceration
rate decreases the cost to the medical
care you're
welcome okay so you'll also see that the
other items under what we calling
operation expenses those stay relatively
static some of those we don't have much
control over with regard to utilities
and heat and things of that nature um
obviously replacing the New Hampshire
state prison for men in the state's
future reduces those costs in general
it's not a very physically efficient uh
infrastructure and then when we go down
to our total operational expenses that
equal a million or less you can see that
those are not climbing drastically in
this budget
proposal uh you also asked about
positions we've stayed relatively static
on the total number of positions in this
department um you'll see we have one
unfunded in order to meet our our
proposed budget Target at the time we
unfunded a correctional Industries
accounting on page
16 uh talk about uh the footnote I
described on overtime I would continue
uh with the footnote associated with
prescription drug expenses and medical
payments to providers because we have to
provide constitutionally appropriate
care and there are definitely some
unpredictable medical uh outliers that
occur in the fiscal year and I think
those are important safety elements for
the department and the
state on page SE uh 17 uh really candid
demonstration of our overtime costs uh
but I also want to point out that the
overtime hours have gone down it's the
cost per hour that has increased and uh
some of that is appropriately the result
of having a more competitive wage with
our other law enforcement U Partners
across the state so we are able to
recruit it's the negotiated double
overtime um and included in this uh
could be other costs around Health Care
staff who are also working over time uh
but mostly this is our law enforcement
Rank and
file uh there was a also a 10% and a 2%
raise so those increases uh really
tackle into this 35% increase in the
overtime
rate uh in the bottom leftand corner try
to give you a trended history of our
sworn or lawn enforcement staff uh some
of you have seen this for the new
members we certainly were hit hard uh
postco with a lot of retirements um the
last fiscal years have showed some
stabilization significant stabilization
in the number of people retiring while
also the movement interaction and
recruiting new law enforcement Rank and
file to our staff and the number 30 just
represents where we are in this current
fiscal year so we're trending in a great
direction that we're already at hiring
30 new law enforcement officers to our
department while we balance retaining
individuals as well
and then our correctional officer
vacancy rate coming down to 42% which is
still scary number but it's a heck of a
lot better than where we were what does
termed
mean that's a good question where are
you reading that sir um SW that thank
you it always throws me up termed means
literally they uh separated from us it
doesn't mean we terminated them it's an
HR term I don't like but it comes out of
the system that way so it could be self
selected departure from the Department
or we could have invited somebody to
depart but they've essentially separated
their employment with us all right so
somebody was working for us and decided
to go work in Massachusetts or something
like that versus choosing to retire I
you a month um do you have a
um do you are you tracking the age of
your employees and do you see a a an
upcoming retirement tsunami or is that
are you past that we I'm going to get
you to some of that on page 21 but I
don't think it has the age Break um and
I can follow up with that so the average
tenure of our staff used to be about 10
years it's now about um eight and so you
actually see a you do see a change in
tenure and then the age range are
changing so we're um I literally just
printed that graph and I I feel a little
silly I should have brought it with me
we do have a call it a a younger group
younger than I group uh but it's still a
nice little uh curve it's not too sharp
um and I'll get that out to the
committee it's it's a normal curve it's
a totally normal curve um and they even
have just for interest of socially
managing groups uh their um generation
so YX Baby Boomers and so forth so if
that's an interest to the committee I'll
welcome on uh page I think the don't
think it has page number but the
following page on page 18 just want to
take a moment and appreciate this
committee and the other members of the
legislature for supporting what I would
call it is the um uh salary stability of
our law enforcement rank shows where we
were in 2022 that we were the lowest
paid State uh law enforcement officers
and now in the bottom right hand corner
you can see our starting pay in
comparison to other counterparts across
the state and then we continue to
monitor our competition in the community
whether it be a County facility or other
local police departments so we' made
great strides and I just wanted to thank
that I'm not seeing where we are we used
to start what page are we talking oh yep
it's the page that followed the overtime
sline yeah y okay so when we came uh
before this committee we had a starting
pay for our Corrections Officers at $20
an hour after the legislatively
supported reallocation now our starting
pay is at 2617 which which makes us more
competitive when you look at the other
law enforcement ranks in state agencies
but also when you look at what local
police departments are paying new law
enforcement officers uh and other County
Corrections departments we are now
competitive rather than being the lowest
paid law enforcement in the state of New
Hampshire oh I see I thought you were
comparing us to other states no no but
we are still competitive gotcha
thank in fact because we have an income
tax we might be more competitive if
that's being publicly heard
on uh page 19 I just wanted to give you
a high level you know because obviously
our strategic plan has been to increase
our staffing um increase our retention
uh targeting technology for efficiency
and and dealing with the infrastructure
issues and I wanted to give you a
calendar year uh just high level road
map of the recruitment initiatives and
retention initiatives that we've been
engaged in uh for several years and I
I'll give you time to to read that but I
I felt it was important to share with
you
and then the following two pages are
more efforts we've done in recruitment
retention we update these very regularly
we get them out to our staff both to
keep them informed of what's going on um
you know how many career fairs we've
gone to 108 community events 35
classroom talks 36 uh college and high
school tours 37 these are important
changes in this department because we
weren't doing this before and uh people
didn't know what a career and
Corrections was and so we're using not
just our law enforcement officers but
our mental health clinicians and our
nurses and our probation andol officers
to really get out there and show our
communities and our young people and
people who are unsure where they want to
take a career uh that there is a career
in Corrections and the other uh piece
we're engaged in is the reality that the
research shows working in Corrections
can be incredibly challenging uh
increases your susceptibility to have
PTSD and other known uh mental health
conditions and we really don't want that
for our uh staff in the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections so we've
created per peer support programs using
Crisis Intervention training and we have
a comfort dog program we've created what
are called Wellness areas in our
Correctional Facilities so if you need
to after an escalated event go to a
space that feels a lot more normative
you can do that um these are tried
andrue research methods and we continue
to try to stay a stride of that
work representative cell thank you Mr
chair did I hear you say do you have
co-op co-op programs there such as with
like a universal like
Northeastern I don't believe I said that
I said Comfort dog programs okay but uh
would you ever consider doing co-op
programs because they have like that law
enforcement College down there and that
might be a good Avenue to get new
recruits I'll check into that yeah we
are teaching um at a high school level
at the Berlin and Groveton high school
and uh as extra uh credit course for
young adults soon to be young adults to
understand there's a career path there
um and I know that some of members of
our team actually teach at the collegial
level uh so there's some opportunities
we've tapped into in that space as well
but that's a great
recommendation thank you uh we have a
family support organization where we've
partnered with the uh loved ones of
people who work in our facilities and
and partnered with them and they do
really unique and thought thoughtful
things like bring incarnations uh so
that our team members can take that
Carnation home because they don't have
time to go buy those things to thank
their loved ones on Valentine's Day
there's also meal sharing and another
one things that we're doing uh within
the department on the following page is
a lot of detail about the process how
many people it takes us in the
recruitment process to get to New highes
um and so we really map through that uh
some of the question asked earlier I've
got the Generations on this one with
regard to gender and the generation in
which they're working uh we do have the
average age at
43 I just have it in a graph back at the
office and the average years of service
I'm glad I'm right 8
.13 uh to the question I believe that
was asked earlier about um retirement
Cliff we have 116 people eligible to
retire today we break them out by our
group one eligible our group two law
enforcement and our group two
Correctional line Personnel who are also
law
enforcement and then I have both our we
refer to them as our civilian staff the
trending and the same trending uh
all right in addition to the questions
you asked you asked about new general
fund
Appropriations one of those
implementations uh was in
2223 we uh had asked uh during the uh
Finance phase of the budget for
additional Appropriations to outfit the
whole of the department and body warrant
cameras and uh that was so afforded to
us so I want to appreciate the
legislature for that um that has been a
successful program and so to the point
of your ask what is funding that will be
asking to maintain that there is
approximately
$445,900 per year to maintain that
program that program has been highly
successful in both uh affirming our
staff have not engaged in wrongdoing uh
we've had numerous allegations we're be
able to quickly demonstrate that our
staff did not engage in excessive use of
force or uh inappropriate dialogue and
they've been incredibly helpful in
addition we did outfit uh 55 of our
department Vehicles primarily our
probation and appr vehicles and our
transport vehicles with in vehicle
cameras and those have been uh
instrumental tool as
well what does these cameras cost per
camera
yes currently have statewide contract
where it's $45 per month per camera $45
per month per camera
okay can you can you
rent so we do use the Statewide purchase
procurement process part of my
hesitation around buying versus renting
is my experience with the Department's
conducted energy weapons we bought we
sat with them they expired there was no
ongoing you sat with this expired
technology so there is this balance but
we will continue to work with the
Department administrative services on
the right approach to that program for
the
state so do you have an idea if you were
to buy what they cost or I don't believe
the bid went out that way okay yeah I
mean like in a catalog or something
anyways all right representative Ms then
representative evil um the the the
footage from these cameras where is that
stored is that stored in the cloud or it
definitely is we use evidence.com and
that's part of the contract as well okay
and you have the prop you have the the
right people that know how to access it
on a timely basis and manage all that
stuff we do right we didn't add any
other staff which is another test with
us adding technology and not adding
resources to manage it but we are
managing it uh the division of
Professional Standards within our
department did Advocate uh to me
recently for one full-time um redaction
so what we're finding and we did not
think about was when defense attorneys
and other individuals need video uh and
or prosecutors need video we didn't
allocate resources to that we're just
trying to absorb it with what we have
and action capability that's when you
like fuzz the images in the background
especially when we go in uh to a home
visit and there's a child or other
things we don't uh that's not
appropriate how do you do that that now
we do it through the evidence.com
redaction process that's in the software
technology oh okay
yeah um maybe you sort of explained this
but could what is in the um
$45,881
is that rental or what it's right I just
wondered if you could break down that
number for us so it's for 520 um body
warn cameras at $45 per month and then
we have technically 110 vehicle cameras
because there's one in the front one in
the back and those are $125 per month I
see and and so this is rental costs to
keep it going it includes the software
that she just talked about too
you thank
you all right yeah on page 23 asked
about uh new position positions
established and so uh going back to 2020
to 2027 we've uh increased from 971 to
973 and that increase was the result of
adding uh re-entry care coordination and
this has been a a piloted project that
started back in
2018 uh when we received funding through
what was at the time State targeted
response dollars which is now State
opioid response dollars um we asked for
funding for a one full-time re-entry
care coordinator to work with women 12
months post relase that had opioid use
disorder in an assertive case management
model what we found under that federally
Grant funded opportunity is it was
successful in reducing returns to
incarceration in that first year so in
2019 we asked for additional
Appropriations under those grants for
two uh reentry care coordinators for men
to follow them 12 months Post Release
under the same methodology so with those
three FTE through the course of 2018
moving forward it did demonstrate
success in reducing what is the highest
risk period for return which is 12
months Post Release as a result of that
and through the budget process in
2022 uh we added three full-time uh
re-entry care coordinators funded
through the state and the reason I asked
for that funding through the state is we
needed the stabilization the one thing
we found is if there were any gaps in
that federally Grant funded we end up
losing people and having times of
vacancy and these really demonstrated
the effectiveness um and I'm trying to
show you that in the chart at the bottom
of page 23 so this is the revolving case
load they're managing each month and
that small red bar are the people that
are returning to incarceration so
they're really keeping people who are at
risk out in the community and uh just
demonstrating why they were established
and how they are effective and include
the cost of their positions on that page
as well
well on the following page it goes into
great depth and detail about their roles
uh certainly leave that to you to read
um we are also doing harm reduction and
that harm reduction uh through the same
pilot providing people the voluntary
opportunity to opioid overdose reversal
drugs actually showed that we're
reducing uh the number of opioid
overdose deaths in the supervised
population again it's voluntary it's not
forced but it is showing a reduction in
overdose deaths
in addition to new positions established
uh Lessons Learned From the work that we
uh had to uh request during covid and
using the National Guard in non-armed
control rooms uh worked with uh the
division of administrative services and
our legal council to create a a
non-benefited um a non full-time
position that we refer to as pum
positions these pum positions have
helped us reduce the forced over time
put people safely in a trained role to
run control rooms while we continue to
recruit for full-time law enforcement
and uh I just wanted to point those out
it has been successful the other reason
it's been successful is some of those
law enforcement retirees want to retire
but they still want to give service and
they don't want to maintain their
certification as law enforcement so
they've elected actually to take these
pum positions and they've already got
the landscape of the department so it's
really a win-win and then the other
value is we've had some college students
come on as pum and then end up becoming
full-time officers so the the benefit
department
okay then number three you asked about
General funds and arpa funds so we did
apply for the sweep tap as it was called
and um were afforded some funding for
that that funding was uh Guardian RFID
technology that technology we are uh
still in the process of deploying it is
to get us off paper based systems on
basic fundamental elements and
Corrections such as conducting rounds
and counts um this technology also will
help us do tool and inventory controls
um and again we're still in the process
of getting it completely outfitted at
all locations and the ongoing um hit to
$378,000 uh let's see underneath uh the
other f in is for fusus technology and
the the ongoing maintenance uh from that
arpa funed project would have uh happen
in 2027 uh for the amount of
$170,000 it is a software subscription
on the following page 27 give a high Lev
overview of that product it also um
really allows us to consolidate all of
our digital information um make it easy
to navigate and get to bring up video
cameras for surveillance in effective
ways uh really increase that efficiency
and transparency throughout the
department so that we can use technology
for efficiency while we continue to sh
up our Staffing
Resources and then I do have one more
page on page
28 uh just pointing out that arpa at one
point was funding a salary enhancement
for our nursing staff that was bargained
into the bargaining agreement and so
those enhancements will continue in 26
27 and so to the this the intent of your
question just wanted to make sure we
included that as
well so that's what I've provided for
you today happy to answer uh questions
or again take those questions and bring
information back let me ask this on page
27 it says here nhdoc faces frequent L
litigation yes so how much are we
talking about here do and I is that all
in the Attorney General's budget or is
it in your
yeah that's a great question I I think I
have just uh become desensitized to the
amount of litigation I experienced as a
ah head of a correctional organization
that is normative across the country and
yes the Attorney General's office has
dedicated legal counsel for us uh
recently been able to take a classified
position and make it a attorney so we've
only just started to have an attorney
liaison within our department between
the attorney generals and
ourselves do you have a sense sense of
the Attorney General has five people
dedicated to this kind of legisl
litigation or something like that or you
know I will definitely let you know that
I have one civil attorney who is our
primary leison who has multiple other
state agencies and then there are
approximately five uh other attorneys
that help manage the criminal matters
and it's my understanding but I would
defer to the attorney general they also
handle other states criminal matters at
the same time we we take a lot of we
take a a lot of time from the Attorney
General's office the the reason I'm
asking these questions is last time we
talked to the attorney general about the
YDC case they said it's up to us to
specify how much we can be sued right so
it's there there's a concept called
sovereign immunity which allows the
state to say well you can only sue me
for this much or this kind of thing or
whatever and so I'm wondering if if
there might be somehow legislative
releas
for some of these costs right so I think
representative I think that's a great
question I am prideful that the
department actually doesn't pay out a
lot of claims so most of the time it's
defending a claim and getting it
dismissed so it's not a a payment except
for the time paid to that attorney's
time but that's still a great
you um so were you requested to cut your
budget by 4% or some percentage and if
so could you I think you've said certain
things but could you be specific in
outlining how you're accomplishing
those
cuts thank you yes on page
15 so this was our first
Target under Governor sununu have I lost
track at this point uh and transitioning
over to Governor aot's office so this is
our this is our first proposal and what
we tried to do is again look at that
overtime line and then our prescription
drug line and medical payments to
Providers line so those are the three
yes that you we did do some other things
but not to the extent of those three
primary Lin B so what would be the
aggregate amount of the cut was that
like 10 14
million between 10 and 14 million
okay and then um just as a general
matter I know you've told us this before
but what what is the cost of
incarceration that may be a hard
question no it's not the per the per day
cost was it 452 I think it's gone up rep
aable it was around 452 but I think we
need to update our calculation and so to
earlier conversation the average cost
per day for parole and supervision is
wow so what I'll I'll do after this
meeting just to sh up those statements
is get you the actual um per day costs
depending where somebody is in our
system and that's the same whether it's
the regardless of the gender yes y
yeah did I hear you say $ five or
something $2 for probation and parole
per day and around $452 but I'm I may be
understating that based on
today's uh fiscal
year I normally publish it in every
annual report and I'm behind say that
again incarceration $452 a day a prison
day per day the last we did the analysis
was around
$452 we need to update that analysis and
the same analysis being on probation and
parole per day was $2 so what I had in
the back of my mind was more like
$50,000 a day for but you're saying it's
yeah for year for year for 50 you know
this is the yearly cost go ahead
8,542 24 for cost of incarceration for
$858
div I see yeah
yeah right yeah it's ridiculous
okay represent thank you Mr chair
um that that's okay I answered most
anything chairman Mr chair um we had I'm
trying to get my hand around um a bill
that was presented us to provide some
funding for Waypoint oh um and because
one of the things that when they came to
the finance committee was that this
money would also help this youth it
would help them with their youth
homeless shelter and find some
incarceration diversion programs and um
also when the judicial branch came last
week to us they're piloting a young
adult Court Pilot so what I want to get
my handle around is of the when you look
at the population by age and you've got
17 to
30 um there I think the ages they're
looking at were um like 18 to 24 17 to
24 something like that um so a few
questions one how many of that
population 17 to 24 um return to
incarceration at some point so like for
instance if we can prevent them from
going in at that age um I'd like to know
the savings we'd have of them having to
be repeat
offenders because it I want to get a
handle that if the if this young adult
court and Waypoint can work together to
reduce incarceration that that savings
may be very coste effective to
supporting their request for
500,000 so that was my my one question
and also how many of those 17 to 30 year
olds come into incarceration from a
homelessness position
and in mental health and and and
substance abuse too just so when we look
at Investments spending we're making in
those areas can we justify them based on
the fact that they're saving us that
$452 per day uh thank you for that I I
really appreciate you bringing that up
I've been working with judge Delker and
we've U made a commitment that we could
manage five individuals in their pilot
for young adult court because we don't
have any extra probation and parle
officers I've not been able to expand
that effort and so even my budget does
not ask for another probation and parole
officer so if the legislature is going
to provide assistance to the young adult
Court we would need at least one
probation and parole officer allocated
to this department to support that
program and it's not just the officer
it's all of the utility we provide them
uh to do their resources Firearms body
warn cameras and things in that nature
to your question I'm not able to let you
know if they were in the status of being
housed prior to incarceration I don't
have any connectivity to that data but I
will share with you that uh from a
prevalence rate uh approximately 45% of
people incarcerated have a substance use
disorder as a primary diagnose and uh
that number does not shift uh when it
comes to other mental health conditions
so I think you can safely assume
whatever this number is of 17 to 30 that
that statistic add that uh percentage
application and they're in that that
group um with regards to um returns um
savings it's really that per day
incarceration rate so any day we can
avoid someone's incarceration or
reincarceration the savings are going to
be based on what we just discussed thank
you very much you're very
welome all right
um other questions from the committee
yes representative Evil all
kinds this is our just for the this is
our largest uh Department right so
that's why we're judge me the question
no we're not we have 50 minutes more so
trying to come up with I'm here for you
okay so I have so my first question is
um on a percentage basis how many people
are in your jail awaiting trial for
extended periods of time or do they go
other places uh representative aable
we're not a Detention Facility so anyone
waiting would be at our County Jail okay
that's what I get confused a little bit
I mean I'm going to give you a caveat
sometimes we uh do an administrative
transfer between the county jails so we
might have one or two persons but it's
very rare okay all right so when they're
detained awaiting trial they're in
County facilities and then once they're
sentenced they come to the state
facility as long as it's a sentence of
one year or more gotcha so uh to add to
your line of questioning there is a
place in law that if a person is serving
for example two misdemeanor sentences
that are concurrent to each other when
they get to day 366 to start that second
one-year sentence at the county level
the County under RSA 31 something calls
us and says do you want to take them or
do you want to pay us a perdm rate for
them to stay
here okay and then um I know again I may
be confusing jurisdictions okay at the
county level I know we've talked a lot
about um having federal prisoners but
that may be a detention situation I mean
do you have anyone that you have for the
federal government or we're maybe a
transfer situation or something I don't
know sorry no that's fair um there's a
lot of overlap it's very very fair and
it's an opportunity to answer a question
to help uh people know we we do not hold
people for federal sentences but to the
point of your last comment we would
transfer someone from the state who then
owes uh the fed's sentence we would
transfer them to the federal government
but we don't have an agreement to hold
people at our facility for the federal
uh Bureau prisons okay all right so I
did a little math and divided good uh
$78,000 a year it's 200 $4 a day okay so
I was no wonder that's getting confused
so it's still a huge number but it's
it's not $400 anyways representative
months thank you Mr chair since you've
um encouraged us to ask more questions
I'm gonna Dive Right In um on page um
page
seven um it looks like there's
166 individuals that are um held in you
know not in a new in in New Hampshire um
can you kind of give us just a kind of a
sense of who those folks are and um
where they are and why they're there and
that and you know what's the relative
cost yep so the there is a Interstate
there's an interstate agreement process
we have memorandums of understanding
with almost every state in the nation um
and they uh with us and what happens is
if an individual for a multi ude of
reasons whether it's uh security threat
groups commonly know to as gangs or
protective custody issues or their crime
in that state is so high-profile we
essentially exchange those individuals
under an agreement process and vetting
process um we've had individuals who
they've asked us to take who were unduly
familiar with staff removing them from
that Correctional environment to ours um
and again it goes through this mutually
rigorous process of Exchange um the cost
is neutralized each state agrees that
the housing cost is absorbed just like
they were in that state and the only
time we might seek costs from one
another is if their health care exceeds
the On-Site Health Care and we do that
through mutual agreement and if in those
instances the off-site health care
starts to exceed what our normative
costs are we actually uh usually seek to
retrieve that person back if we can
resolve the reason we sent them out in
the beginning so apparently I've been
asking all of the same questions that
representative run wants to ask so I'm
going to see if I'm following up with
the right question um so how many outof
state um P prisoners do we have I mean
how many from from other states are in
New Hampshire we try to do a one for one
okay so if we have 166 out we generally
have 166 in we try it's usually that's
the case all right thanks you're welcome
so the I mean the general idea is if
people commit crimes together they don't
want them in the same prison together
they want maybe one in Berlin one in
conquer and one in Massachusetts or
something like that right so that's a
great example um and we just don't have
the same diverse physical capacity as
other jurisdictions have yeah so um let
me ask this about the the population do
you have sense of how many what fraction
of them grew up in New Hampshire versus
grew up elsewhere and committed crimes
in New Hampshire I I love that question
because I don't have the answer to it
and I want to know um all I can share
with you is individuals when they get to
the time of parole there's another
agreement uh both embedded in our state
law where we participate in an
interstate compact supervision process
um I'm going to lean into that because I
do have cases where it looks like they
came here to visit committed a crime
here and now they're staying here and we
go through that at the time of parole
release they try to parole back to their
I call it original state Dan yes
representative
Griffin thank you um can you talk to us
about the
facilities and the condition of them and
the cost of them and yeah give us an
update on the overall facilities we know
there's
longterm plans for a new a new Men's
prison the woman's prison is only a few
years old so that could be in pretty
good shape I I think it'd be helpful if
you could give us an update on them I'd
be happy to do that thank you for that
question the uh 10 original $10 million
allocated as well on its way and there's
a lot of work going on on geological
analysis of the property behind the New
Hampshire correctional facility for
women uh to make sure we could build a
replacement facility there and that's
looking very good at this point the
additional uh 40 million doll allocation
is going out for what's called RFI it's
a new term I learned from my partners
over at Department of Public Works uh to
solicit interest in the state to then
have those individuals who respond to
that RFI be interested in the request
for proposal that will go out in March
for the additional $40 million and that
$40 million will result in um actual
construction documents that can then be
put out to bid to get to a firm cost on
building a replacement of the New
Hampshire state prison for men um you
are right the the Hampshire correctional
facility for women is in generally good
shape we had some uh warranty issues
with the boilers uh but that's been
resolved and headed in the right
direction the New Hampshire correctional
facility for um northern New Hampshire
Correctional Facility needs general
maintenance um and I believe with the
capital budget Appropriations the last
go around we're headed in the right
directions on roof and perimeter
security and things of that nature to
resolve them and electrical controls so
that's good and and we'll put forward
anything we need to move forward when it
comes to the New Hampshire state prison
for men that has really become a very
unpredictable state uh lost a boiler and
through our partnership and we have
three through our partnership at admin
Services they helped us get uh one that
we basically are parking outside while
another boiler went down um it's
becoming very unpredictable at this
point and we're just doing our best to
work both across other state agencies to
hold that infrastructure together while
we get to the conclusion of U this major
project to replace it we have been
actively working to get the HVAC project
that was funded through arpa to the
Finish Line I uh will tell you I went
through the whole medium custody South
with my lieutenant because on the
coldest day this year it wasn't working
and we couldn't figure it out but the
vendor did come in and help us get to
resolve um it's sometimes interesting
trying to improve the infrastructure on
the old infrastructure and making it
work uh one of the areas I think that
will have a concern with as the years
continue before we replace it is the
refrigerant which is no longer FDA
approved and we have to buy used
refrigerant in some of the areas of the
infrastructure specifically reception
and diagnostic um so I will continue to
keep you apprised of that infrastructure
and I really value you asking that
question would it be possible to expand
the Berlin Facility by adding another
Wing or two is there land is there you
know because it you already sort of have
a basic design so so represent McGuire
that uh facility was designed in 2000 to
essentially drop a wing on it as they
said you could do some expansion my
hesitation is Could you actually recruit
the staff to move there and to work
there and to provide uh the resources
and I'm not sure that we would be
successful given that we have this
Central Mass of Staff now here in
conquered whether they would move to
work that would be considered cheaper
than a brand new one in conquer right
yeah I'm not I'm not sure we could add
1,400 people up there yeah I don't not
necessarily everybody but you know some
yeah representative rung thank you Mr
chair um going back to your population
um I was on a school board for many
years and we used to put a full court
press out if there was any student that
was considering dropping out and you
know we knew that you know you drop out
you're a higher risk of incarceration so
when we look at that population
particularly the 17 to 30 17 to 30
population how many of those are high
school
graduates uh I will see if we have that
information I think we do okay um but I
don't have it right off hand okay thank
welcome more
questions all right representative
people
okay I was just curious roughly what the
capital budget is for improvements this
time around uh for the correctional
facility here in conquer repres how much
money are we shoveling in see if my
estimate I remember talking about all
these things I know I don't think my
brain was ready for that question you
got me today yeah well it isn't the it
isn't public works but it's just an
interesting contrast when you're talking
about the cost of building a new prison
so we had a total of 15 projects on the
slide that we discussed and that total
was $693
Million our top three
projects when I well let me subtract off
a new facility because that's where that
number is coming from our top three
projects are our New Hampshire state
prison for men the steam lines and traps
around
3.5 uh the replacement of the body alarm
manown system at our Northern New
Hampshire Correctional Facility is
1.8 and then um replacing the boilers
has moved up in our priority because of
what I just described earlier and that's
around $2.1 million at New Hampshire
state pris for men so about five and a
half six million just in the top
possibility
add offic
have interested
yeah it is an interesting question we
have enough vacancies that if people
wanted to move they could transfer now
but yeah I mean I think that's the other
important reality and it's usually a
whole family you're relocating the whole
family and then your spouse's employment
and all of those efforts but uh I
believe that right now we have enough
people that could move if they wanted to
today but it's a fair question yeah and
I think um Berlin has done a reasonable
job of making their Community more
attractive right I mean they're
improving it and so more tourism and all
that kind of I think the Berlin and gorm
Community is gorgeous uh it's it's the
diversity of professionals to run the
Department of Correction so licensed
clinicians having enough of them um
licensed nursing staff the list of those
Diversified professionals is
significant yeah
shall we uh call it a day for this and
come back at 3 o' yeah I I got
appreciate everyone's questions and if
there's anything you think of after let
us know we'll do our best all right well
thank you very much commissioner we'll
see you appreciate that we'll see you uh
thank you in a few weeks I think see you
soon
yeah update that number on the per day
charge for incarceration first thing I'm
going to do when I go back why why is it
stuck in my head at 4 52 because I hate
to be wrong yeah well yeah but it had to
have been somewhere and I want to make
sure we have it right okay did you
update the website with the counts and
some of those things we're working on
updating some information I can get up
right away and I'm working in parallel
to get our FY 23 and fy2 24 report uh
you
e
so it is 3:00 and we will welcome the
Attorney General um to talk about the
thank you Mr chairman uh members of the
committee just for the record my name is
John formela serving as attorney general
with me is Kathy Carr who is our
director of administration so she helps
put together our budget and when I say
helps I'm not giving her enough credit
she basically put together our
budget uh so thank you for having us
here today
um I I thought it might make sense I
know this is the agency overview
presentation and and we got some
specific questions I figured it would
make sense for us to do the overview and
then we can address the specific
questions that were received ises that
work yeah yeah I think we have like an
hour and a half available I don't know
if it'll take that long but okay go for
it great well we'll stay as long as you
need us to
um so we we brought a PowerPoint
presentation uh for those of you who
were on this division two years ago it's
going to look pretty similar to what you
saw before there a couple new things um
for anyone who's new be seeing it for
the first time um but uh this is just
meant to to give an overview and because
we're lawyers we put our little disclaim
disclaimer on the front that it's meant
to hit all of the major functions we do
if I forget a small function or two I I
apologize we may have missed one or two
small functions um on the second page of
the presentation you will see an or
chart and I'm going to walk through all
of these functions but this gives you a
good snapshot of of how the how the
office looks so at the top there you see
the the senior staff a lot of that is
what we kind of consider the front
office staff and and you can work down
the or chart but I think it will be more
productive if I just talk about these in
more detail as I walk through the
presentation but you can refer back to
this to get a sense of where everything
fits in the in the overall
structure on the next page of the
presentation we just give you our
estimated funding breakdown I say
estimated funding breakdown because
these numbers come from the fiscal year
2026 numbers in our agency budget
submission so of course that's just the
agency budget submission I don't want to
get out in front of the governor she'll
be presenting her budget next week I
expect it'll look roughly the same but
these numbers could change a little bit
depending on what changes she makes to
our budget but that gives you a sense of
the funding of the Department of Justice
we are well under
50% um General funds although creeping a
little closer to 50% than we have been
in the past and we're also funded by
federal funds Highway funds uh inter
agency funds and then some other other
funding
sources the next page of the
presentation just give some bullets on
the various roles of of the Attorney
General and and through the Attorney
General the Department of Justice the
first role of the attorney general which
is the role that I think most people
think about first when they when they
think of us as chief law enforcement
officer so the Attorney General is the
chief law enforcement officer of the
state according to our statutes and
provides leadership and supervision to
the law enforcement Community the
Attorney General is also the chief
prosecutor so we both prosecute major
criminal cases directly in the
Department of Justice we also exercise a
supervisory role over all local
prosecutors in the State uh we we work
pretty closely with the County attorneys
we don't we try not to micromanage what
they do they operate with a lot of
Independence but we meet with the County
attorneys I meet with them every other
month we talk about the cases that are
going on around the state we talk about
strategies talk about ways to just keep
what we're doing consistent across the
state every county is a little bit
different and of course uh depending on
how a judge or judges in particular
counties are cases might be might
proceed a little bit differently you
might get a little bit different
outcomes but for the most part things
are pretty consistent throughout the
state and we try to stay coordinated
with prosecutors around the state to
keep that keep that the case the
Attorney General is also the the chief
legal officer so in that role we both
represent the state in civil litigation
so we're defending the state when the
state gets sued and we represent all
three branches of government in that
capacity so if if executive branch
officials get sued in their official
capacity if legislators get sued in your
official capacity we we might represent
you we actually sometimes represent
judges or members of the J other staff
in the judicial branch when they're sued
uh
over you know administrative things
right so if if a if a judge for instance
is sued because there's an alligation
that they did something inappropriate
with some employment process we might be
representing that judge if we represent
that judge we make sure that the lawyers
who are representing that judge don't
appear in front of that judge either
while they're representing that judge or
anytime close to when they represent
that judge but it's a pretty broad role
that the office has to represent the
state when the state gets sued the
office also acts as a client counselor
for executive branch agencies and the
judicial branch sometimes the
legislature so not necessarily
representing you in in court but just
giving legal advice weighing in on on
things um helping make sure things stay
legal so that we don't get sued so I
think of the client counseling function
as the function that tries to prevent
the state from getting sued in the first
place the litigation function is the
part of us that represents the state in
court if we if we do end up getting
sued the other two roles of the AG uh I
I I like to think of another role as
being the chief public Protection
Officer so that that's slightly
different from being the chief law
enforcement officer the chief prosecutor
because we do a lot of public protection
functions that some might not think of
as law enforcement or prosecutorial
functions but they are public protection
functions one example is the charitable
trust unit overseeing the charities in
the state um both assisting Charities
and also ensuring they comply with the
law taking enforcement action if
necessary if someone is embezzling funds
from a charity or or uh more I would say
the more uh public protection non
prosecutorial function is maybe doing a
civil enforcement action if a board of
directors is not fulfilling its
fiduciary obl obligations to a charity
another example is Environmental
Protection it's not most of the time a
criminal function but it is a public
protection function if someone's
violating the environmental laws of the
state and we take some type of civil
enforcement action get a civil penalty
that's a public protection function it's
not what people think of necessarily
when they think of the the law
enforcement or prosecutorial function
because it's not a it's not a criminal
action and then of course the attorney
general has to be the head of a
department so the fifth job of the
Attorney General is to to be a
department head so all the
administrative work that comes along
with that
representative M thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr attorney general AB um the
the could you could you talk a little
bit more about the the relationship
between your office and the and the
County attorneys
um you know I guess what I'm trying to
understand is it's not the same as the
federal state relationship right because
I mean you're you're both within the
same jurisdiction you're both I guess
responsible for the same set of laws yes
um
um my questions are you know kind of an
organizational one which is you know do
you have you know as the chief
Prosecuting officer do you have um kind
of ultimate say over what they can and
can't do uh and what areas do they
pursue versus what areas do your
assistant attorney generals pursue yep
it's a great question thank thank you
representative so I'll start with with
the the broad uh sort of the broad
authority of the AG the attorney general
has uh broad jurisdiction in this state
so ultimate responsibility for the
prosecution of the criminal laws rests
with the attorney general but the County
attorneys are independently elected and
the County attorneys and other local
prosecutors they handle most of the
criminal
cases they operate independently most of
the time they set their own priorities
they determine you know how they're
going to approach cases they make the
county attorney will make the ultimate
decision for uh whether they're going to
resolve cases in their particular County
whether they're going to try the cases
what type of sentences they're they're
going to pursue um that said if
something is not going well in a
particular County or there are issues
the Attorney General can step in and
assume control of those functions it
doesn't happen often it happens from
time to time so the attorney general has
ultimate control
over that but but largely though that
function is delegated to to County
attorneys the AG does have to
approve the hiring of assistant County
attorneys so any assistant County
attorney in the state that's hired comes
through our office and we review that
and we sign off on those hires and like
I said we do do a lot of coordination
and training but um did does that cover
your question I might have missed a
couple parts of it um yeah that I guess
the one question is um you know when
does you know you if you watch TV you've
got the County Prosecutors is
Prosecuting a case but then there are
certain cases where the Assistant
Attorney General is Prosecuting the case
what what who determines that yeah so
there are there is a relatively select
category of cases where we we handle the
cases exclusively one example are murder
cases so second deegree murder and up we
do all of those cases so if it's a
second deegree murder case or first
degree murder case that that will be our
office we exclusively handle public
Integrity cases involving law
enforcement officers or state officials
that's that's our office we do Medicaid
fraud control so if it if there's a
Medicaid fraud criminal case that will
be just our office we do I would say the
most significant drug cases the county
the County attorneys do Mo the vast
majority of the drug cases but we do
some of the more significant drug
cases we right now we're handling the
YDC cases that's that's a unique
situation we normally would not do
sexual assault cases but this is a I
think for obvious reasons a that's a
unique set of circumstances and a very
complicated situation so we are we're
handling that so those are the those are
the types of criminal cases that that we
that we do that said if there's a unique
type of situation where we need to step
in might not fall into one of those
categories we may take the case we'll
sometimes take a white collar type theft
case or something like that that would
normally be handled by the County
Attorney if it's complicated enough that
you need the resources of the Department
of Justice to handle it so you have you
have the right and the ability to to to
step in at any point say yep we're going
to take that one opposed to you Mr
County attorney cor yes and we also
handle all of the Criminal Appeals so
any criminal case in the state if
there's an appeal our Criminal Appeals
Unit handles handles
those does that is that possibly
inefficient in the sense that your
attorney hasn't necessarily worked on
the case whereas the county person has
and has all the experience and so
on I actually think overall it's a very
efficient way to do it you know there
that sometimes can present some
challenges where we haven't tried the
case but we're handling the appeal that
said when you're deciding whether to
take an appeal in a case and you're
deciding what arguments to make you
really want to be uniform across the
state you wouldn't want different
counties taking different positions on
appeal before The Supreme Court I think
you you want to have a central spot
where you're determining what issues
you're going to take up what positions
are you going to take tracking the
results of various appeals so you can
track the state of the law and of course
our goal as the Attorney General's
office is to try to shape the law in a
way that's favorable to law enforcement
and criminal prosecution so I I think
it's actually a good way to operate
every now and then there can be
challenges with the fact that we didn't
try the case but in this state we're
pretty well integrated with the county
attorney offices we're we're not we're
not an enormous State either population
wise or or Geographic wise we talk to
the County attorneys a lot and there's a
lot of good coordination back and forth
and I suppose also there might be some
cases where um the County Attorney would
want to appear appeal lost the case and
would want to appeal and you look at it
and say this this isn't that great a
case and therefore we're going to pass
or something like that correct there are
times when we might look at it and and
we and we the County Attorney lost and
we say well we we we think you lost and
you probably should have lost right we
don't think an appeal is warranted or
even if we think maybe the judge got it
wrong it's just not a good situation
which to take an appeal we'll wait for a
different case to appeal that issue
representative R thank you Mr chair how
many employees do you have and what's uh
do you have any positions that are
vacant I did see one on the or chart for
a training attorney yeah and and just to
a lot of the questions I was going to
get to I'm happy to answer them now but
but I I'm but I'll answer that so we
have if you count temporary positions I
think we have
213 total positions permanent positions
I believe it's
195 yeah and I think our vacancies are
with permanent positions I think it's
it's 19 it's 18 or 19 vacancies out of
the permanent positions are those all
full-time full fulltime yeah these are
all yeah so 195 permanent full-time
positions I believe is it 19 vacancies
there yeah 19 vacancies which is a
rate continue with the presentation okay
great so the next slide we've got here
is just uh who does the Attorney General
represent and I know I kind of already
covered that so we we represent in in
many cases State officials either in the
legislative branch executive branch or
judicial
branch on the next next slide or other
side of that slide we represent the
public
so in discrimination claims we represent
the public in our law enforcement
function we represent the public in our
charitable trust oversight function we
represent the public in our through our
Consumer Protection Bureau protecting
consumers we represent the public in
election law enforcement we and uh we
represent the public it's kind of
covered above but in in a civil rights
enforcement on the next slide I just
have a little bit here about client
service versus independent obligations
and Authority so at the Attorney
General's office we're always thinking
carefully about how to balance our role
as being the lawyer for the state so
having clients who who are State
officials and and who we work for and we
try to help them get done what they want
to get done within the bounds of the law
we balance those obligations with what
we see as an independent obligation from
Our obligation to our clients
to ensure that the law is being complied
with to act in the public
interest conduct our law enforcement
functions so enforce the laws of the
state protect the public determine the
best legal position for the state to
take so there there are times it doesn't
happen that often but there are times
when a when an agency when a
commissioner wants to take a certain
legal position and we will not agree
with that and we'll say we're we're not
going to take that position we're going
to take this position because we think
it's in the state's overall best
interest to take this position those
disputes don't happen often but when
they do it's It ultimately falls to the
attorney general to to resolve that
there are also times when state agencies
want to take contrary positions in in a
particular matter they might actually be
litigating against each other or they
may have a different view on a certain
question of
law when a case comes up and they each
have different opinions as to say what
we should argue to the state supreme
court the AG or the Attorney General's
office has the role of resolving those
disputes and having to make the decision
as to what's what's the best position to
take given all of the interests involved
so it really is it's it's a it's a
function that requires us to try to
balancing thank you thanks for taking
the question again um so you know you
the state is your
client but who within the state I mean
you know what if and I guess what I'm
getting at is what if the executive
branch and the legislative branch have a
difference of opinion and the
legislative branch for example wants the
AG to do this and the governor wants you
to do that how does that get
resolved yeah like I said I think it
gets resolved if there is that type of
conflict by the the attorney general
need to needing to determine what's in
the state's best interests now the
Attorney General is also a member of the
executive branch right so in many way in
many ways subordinate to the governor um
when you look at the history of the
position of attorney general in this
state and other states it's it's
interesting because there I've always
viewed it as many many functions the
Attorney General needs to follow the
directive of of the governor that said
there are just some some
responsibilities that exist going back
to the common law that haven't really
been changed in the state either by
Statute or or the Constitution that
involved you know the Attorney General's
obligation to act in the best interest
of the public and and the state so I I
think ultimately if you're the AG
whoever the AG is whoever happens to sit
in the seat just needs to think really
carefully about what the issue is and
whether it's one of those issues where
they need to take the direction of say
the chief executive of the executive
branch or whether it's a unique issue in
which they need to independently
determine what the best course of action
is and it depends on on the category of
of uh of Duty to in the in the criminal
law realm in the law enforcement
criminal law realm I think the Attorney
General really acts independently even
of the governor in the Civil realm where
the AG is acting as the lawyer for the
executive branch I think the Attorney
General needs to do what the governor
tells him or her to do because the
governor is the chief executive of the
executive branch right if it's a dispute
between two branches of government then
it gets more complicated so it you just
you there are some there can be some
complicated questions some tough
judgment calls and you just have to
think really hard about it and and make
the right
call I think you answered my question I
mean and I I think you're right I mean
you you are a member of the executive
branch yes ult ultimately that's kind of
that's that's where where it sits so y I
understand y thank you you have a
five-year term fouryear term four years
okay and um I think the Attorney General
is mentioned in the Constitution yes yes
the Attorney General is mentioned in the
Constitution there's no specific duties
set out for the AG in the Constitution
so there are common law Powers uh that
predate the Constitution and our
statutes but there are a lot of Duties
and authorities that are laid out in in
thank so the next slide we get into just
the the core structure of of the
Department of Justice and this is just
going into a little more detail than
what we had on the uh the org
chart so for many of the substantive
functions for the core uh of the
department were broken down into two
divisions the first division is the
division of public protection with a
couple of exceptions this is basic
basically where the criminal and law
enforcement functions of the department
live the biggest bureau by far in the
office is the criminal justice Bureau
and this has the homicide unit the drug
unit the public Integrity unit the
Medicaid fraud control unit we have a
YDC unit right now that's a temporary
unit but we think of it as it as its own
as its own unit um so this this it has
multiple units that deal with various
categories of of criminal cases we have
the consumer protection antitrust
Bureau this is a this is a large Bureau
it does Elder elder abuse and financial
exploitation uh does Consumer prot kind
of classic consumer protection cases
like going after contractors who rip
people off you know promise to fix your
roof and take the money that you pay
them and never do the work we do those
types of cases we do antitrust cases in
the Consumer Protection Bureau
um you'll see that come up a lot in
hospital mergers the Consumer Protection
Bureau is one of the bureaus that
reviews Hospital mergers to determine
whether the merger violates antitrust
law by reducing competition in our
healthc care market so the Consumer
Protection Bureau is is is the next
biggest bureau in the office after the
criminal justice Bureau and that uh
division of public protection also has
the Environmental Protection Bureau so
the Environmental Protection Bureau is
not really a criminal law Bureau but it
lives in the division of public
protection because there
are rare instances where we can bring
criminal cases in the environmental
context we only do that in really
egregious cases where where someone
might you know may may actually like a a
human being may suffer immediate and
direct harm that that can happen every
now and then in the environmental
context the other
division that houses most of the rest of
the office is the division of legal
counsel so this with a couple of
exceptions mostly has the Civil
functions of the office so the civil law
Bureau which does client counseling and
and civil litigation as I talked about
so both advises State officials and
tries to prevent us from getting sued
and then defending State officials if we
do get sued that's the civil law
Bureau representative cambrell thank you
Mr chair I apologize but just going back
one to the Environmental Protection
Bureau would you get referrals from Dees
or can uh citizens reach out to you
directly for something citizens can
reach out to us directly but a lot of
our cases in that Bureau do come through
referral from Dees okay thank you
yep representative R thank you and um
following up um on that question
so some of the um statutes on
Environmental protection rely on peace
officers to enforce it um which I I'm
assuming is any law enforcement anybody
who has the ability to arrest somebody
in the state do you inter any interface
at all with any of those cases I mean it
could be somebody that's clear cutting a
Shoreland or something like that sure
yeah sometimes it it it's fairly rare
from at least in my experience that
police off peace officers police
officers are involved in environmental
CA in the environmental cases at least
that we work on but it it does happen
but it's
usually usually the way a a an
environmental case that our office
handles arises comes through Dees so
somebody will report to Dees that
someone has is either uh not handling
their hazardous waste correctly or they
not handling storm water correctly or
they're they've got a discharge into a
body of water that they shouldn't have
you know something looks funny to them
they report it to Dees Dees investigates
they can investigate with the assistance
of local law enforcement if they need to
but they investigate and if they put
together a case that they think needs to
be where enforcement action needs to
happen they refer it to us and we take
it from there working with them okay I
yep uh the next Bureau and I actually I
apologize I didn't update this from two
years ago because we've changed the name
of this buau bu but this is the public
safety and infrastructure Bureau used to
be called transportation and
construction this Bureau represents the
department of safety and the Department
of Transportation so they do both
litigation and client counseling for
those two
departments uh the division of legal
council also has the charitable trust
unit the charitable trust unit carries
out what is uh perhaps the oldest
function actually of the Attorney
General in Most states which is to
oversee charities so they Charities are
kind of this interesting uh quasi public
private asset and the the Attorney
General at the end of the day if
something goes wrong with a charity is
the enforcement is the enforcement arm
that comes in and tries to set things
right uh the debt Recovery Unit also
exists in the division of legal council
this is exactly what it sounds like if
there are debts owed to the state that
haven't been paid and and haven't been
able to be collected through other
mechanisms through various departments
we have a debt Recovery Unit that can
take action to try to recover debts owed
to the state often if it gets to that
point the amount we're collecting is you
know Pennies on the Pennies on the
dollar but it's better than nothing you
know it's better than I'd rather collect
some amount of money than than no amount
of money even if it's only a small
percentage of of what's owed so that's
the debt Recovery Unit and then we have
the election law unit is in the division
of legal council this is one of the
exceptions I talked about we do bring
criminal cases and our election law unit
I think as most people know it's
actually housed in the Civil part of the
office since that unit does both civil
and criminal but the election law unit
is in the division of legal council and
then the Civil Rights unit is in the
division of legal council the Civil
Rights unit only brings civil actions so
we file a civil rights action it it can
kind of look and sound like a criminal
case but it's a civil action so we not
charging somebody with a crime we are
trying to stop them from violating the
Civil Rights Act and perhaps seeking
fines and other relief uh as a
consequence for violating thei violating
the Civil Rights Act but it's not a
criminal function in the
office there's a couple there's a few
other parts of the office that exist
outside of those cases that come from
the Human Rights Commission is
that not really the Civil Rights unit
provides client counseling to the Human
Rights Commission but the the the Civil
Rights unit brings cases on its own
every now and then we may hear of
something through the Human Rights
Commission but the Human Rights
Commission is more of an adjudicatory
body so that's where somebody goes if
they say a business let's like let's say
my employer discriminated against me in
the hiring process or um this hotel
would not rent me a room because you
know I'm part of a protected class you
would file a complaint with the Human
Rights Commission the Civil Rights Act
those actions are more like somebody uh
caused physical harm to me because I'm
part I'm you know part of a protected
class or they damaged my property
because I'm part of a protected class or
they trespassed on my property and
harassed me because I'm part of a
protected class that's the Civil Rights
action so they're they're similar things
but they're they're different so one's
more all about employment and the other
is other kind of cases is that uh well
emplo yeah employment public
accommodations right so being
discriminated against in like hotels
restaurants
housing that's a Human Rights Commission
yeah yeah so uh not not sort of like
damage to sell for property
discrimination dis like dis I was
discriminated against not directly
damaged in my either physical physical
harm or property damage now is that
completely independent of your office
the Human Rights Commission they are
administratively attached to to the
office and that's one of the questions
we were asked to address today as to
whether we think we we think that makes
sense or that should continue yeah so I
can address that now or wait till the
end yeah as long as we're on it why
don't we talk about it yeah yeah so I I
think the Human Rights Commission became
administratively attached to us pretty
2020 I am not and and while I was in the
governor's office at the time so I
confess maybe I should remember why that
happened I don't have a very clear
memory as to why that happened I I I
think there is there's been some thought
in the last few years that small
agencies that maybe don't have the
resources to
handle all of the administrative
functions you need to handle to to be an
independent agency should be attached to
some bigger agency that makes sense just
for efficiencies so that we don't have
to have you know a whole new set of HR
and administrative functions for a very
small agency and I
think when we were looking around at
some point a determination was made that
the Human Rights
Commission needs to remain independent
for obvious reasons being it's be its
own agency but needs some support and
given that it's this adjudicatory body
that frankly could have claims from
another from a state agency right I mean
somebody can bring a Human Rights
Commission complaint that involves an
allegation that a state agency
discriminated against them the thought
was the Department of Justice is a good
agency to be attached to since we are
kind of We're the state law enforcement
agency really we the chief law
enforcement agency
um follow up
it does every state have a Human Rights
Commission or something
similar I don't know the exact answer to
that off the top of my head I think Most
states do but but I don't know the
numbers on that we could get back to you
on that I mean is the thought that you
have this because otherwise the courts
would be clogged with these kind of
that as to why the commission exists in
the first place yes I think that's part
of it I think there's also
it's also because of the thought that
these are the types of cases where maybe
you don't want to make someone go into
court that can be intimidating for for
people give them a alternative Forum
that is kind of like a court but doesn't
feel as much like a court as a as a
court that you know people might be more
comfortable bringing a discrimination
claim to a body that deals exclusively
with discrimination claims than with
with a court that is that is more
intimidating to people in certain
circumstances and courts do a do I mean
they they adjudicate every type of case
right they don't specialize in
discrimination claims so I think I think
that is the thinking behind it um
whether that's a policy choice that
should be
reexamined I think is a is a deeper
question that might go beyond a budget
presentation yeah all right
representative Ms just a follow up on
that I mean is the is the the the the
service that you're providing to the
Human Rights
Commission um you know the
administrative Services you're providing
to them you know what what are those
services and does it have anything to do
with the law or is it purely
administrative
it's the the services we provide because
the HRC is administratively attached to
us is purely administrative we do just
like we do for every agency provide
client counseling services to the Human
Rights Commission where we give them
legal advice but we do that for every
agency not just ones that are attached
it's really just it's administrative
like accounts payable yeah accounts
payable um some employment stuff payroll
you know posting hiring postings we
assist them with their budget process
all the stuff you went to law school for
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah all the stuff I
have to rely on someone else to think
about because I went to law school right
yeah we'll talk about this after okay go
ahead with the rest of it okay on the
next slide we just have the the other
components of the doj so we have an
office of solicitor general that's
actually fairly new uh in 2018 the
position of solicitor general was
established in our office for the first
time most attorney general offices
around the country have a solicitor
general and the solicitor general
basically is responsible for all of the
appeals in the office so mentioned
earlier we do all of the Criminal
Appeals for for the state and we also
have a lot of big civil cases that that
we have appeals for so we have do
criminal and Civil Appeals the solicitor
general handles that and the office of
the solicor general is sort of separate
from the division of public protection
and division of legal councel because it
really does do a lot of criminal work
and a lot of civil work so it's it's
outside of those two divisions because
it because it does both function
the office of the chief medical examiner
is housed Under the doj Umbrella the
medical examiner that those are there
are forensic Pathologists so they they
do autopsies they both investigate uh
untimely and suspicious deaths they they
do
autopsies they are the ones that sign
off on death certificates that function
is housed within the Department of
Justice uh the way the medical examiner
puts it which I think is a good way to
think about it is they are
diagnostically independent
meaning they are medical doctors they
make determinations as to what they
think with regard to autopsies and other
scientific questions independently from
the attorney general but they are
administratively um subject to the
direction of of the Attorney General
ultimately since they're part of the
Department of
Justice and then we have uh
administrative functions so this Kathy
is the director of administration
oversees the the director of Law Office
infrastructure he's another word for
that is he's our Tech guy he's our Tech
Guy uh the business office handles
payroll and and things like that we have
a victims compensation unit so there is
a victims compensation fund uh victims
of crime in in New Hampshire can seek
compensation and reimbursement for
certain expenses that they incur as
victims of crime that has to be
connected to a a Charged case so that
only comes into play if we have if we've
either charged a criminal case or we we
think we're going to be charging it
doesn't come into play for anyone who
might just allege that they're a victim
does this sometimes happen at the county
level also or is it all done through
your
office victim's compensation is all done
through our office okay
victim services or victim Advocates
exist at the county level I see so if a
victim of crime in a Charged case can
get assistance from a victim Advocate
and the counties have their own victim
Advocates so we have our victim
Advocates Counties have their victim
Advocates they can help connect them
with Services navigate the criminal
justice process the the victim's
compensation that's housed just within
our office but it it covers victims for
charged crimes whether it's the county
attorney who charged charged or or us
because I think representative Griffin
is uh had a positive experience with
this right I mean for you got a check
right you didn't you get a check after
your car was keyed yeah yeah at at this
Republican
meeting we had the
Republican the school there were like 30
CS that got
key so I put a report in and they told
me to get an estimate and it's about a
year but last week I went to my mailbox
and was $2100 something in my mailbox
which interesting yeah I don't think
that it's probably just a similar
concept that maybe is they had locally
but it's not that's not the type of
thing our like a Vic our victim's
compensation
unit right he caught the perpetrator yep
and he he apparently had asset yep and
that will happen uh when when we charge
crimes right off and we will try to get
to the extent you've you've cause damage
to the victim so Financial loss we'll
try to get restitution for the victim
that though comes from the perpetrator
themselves not from the victim's
compensation fund which is more for say
I'm a victim of crime and because of
this I need counseling right so I can go
to I can potentially get some money for
that from the victim's compensation fund
and this is a general fund fund is that
no no it comes from Criminal criminal
fines and penalties get deposited in
there yeah which which otherwise would
be in the general funds correct yeah I
mean money is fungible at the end of the
day but it that's it comes directly from
that I understand thank you
representative
Ms sorry to ask another question I
actually I have this question for M Miss
Carr if it's all right
um um so part of your duties is oversee
payroll yes what what does that entail I
mean do you have your own payroll do are
do you have your own payroll system
that's unique to the doj or you you
leveraging some other broader State
system so we use what's called New
Hampshire first um it is the state the
executive branch uses that it's all
their financials it's all Inc compassing
it handles your accounts payable your
accounts receivable and your payroll
um
functions so so so are you are you
entering the data and then generating
the paychecks or is that no so uh we use
what's called workforce management now
that just came into effect in November
and our
um our staff our hourly staff enter they
clock in they clock out and then that
gets integrated into New Hampshire first
and all those fun functions the actual
we check everything we double check
everything um all of that is handled
services so I've kind of run through the
overall structure here because I'm a
lawyer and I like to go into detail but
you know I the rest of a lot of the rest
of the PowerPoint just starts to go into
more detail of each of the bureaus I
don't know if not sure I need to talk
through that for purpose of today's
presentation I can just kind of note
what's here and if there are questions
the next slide I just break down the
various units and various parts of the
criminal justice Bureau is this YDC unit
new is this for the case or is that
something else yeah the the YDC unit is
is a is what I would call a temporary
unit the reality is that it there's only
a couple of employees who are really
dedicated to that unit but then we have
probably 10 to 12 attorneys
across the bureau who are handling YDC
cases so we think of it as its own unit
because it's just a good way to organize
it internally but it hasn't resulted in
a lot of extra employees it's resulted
in spreading work across a lot of
existing employees in in the
bureau yeah representa cell thank you Mr
chair given given the situation of YDC
and the way it's headed uh is there any
concern or danger that prisoners at the
state prison will start making claims
that they're they've been abused or
molested and they they will have
lawsuits uh is that happening or can it
happen
we yeah there's a couple different
answers to that so I mean we have had
cases that allege that um I can't say
it's impossible that we'll get you know
that a large number of those cases but I
will
but I I would not expect to see the same
type of
situation in the adult from the adult
population of our prisons
because one of the Dynamics that's at
play when you're dealing with kids so
kids who were
incarcerated is that for many years I
mean before now but decades ago the way
we would treat incarcerated kids would
be
I would say far too similar to adults
but they I think kids would have a lot
harder time reporting something like
that and there's there's a lot more
reason to think that those types of
cases would go
unreported when when you had child
victims because kids don't necessarily
know that something like that is
happening to them if it's happening to
them that it's that it's wrong or
illegal I mean they that it's obviously
not it's a traumatizing experience
but if you're an
incarcerated youth you're not
necessarily going to think to report
something like that adults are doing it
adults in
this government facility that you've
been put into are doing it so you would
have reasons to to not report I don't
expect that we would see nearly the same
volume of unreported cases in an adult
incarcerated
population that doesn't mean we may not
see allegations but I would I would look
on those types of allegations with a lot
more skepticism than I would look on the
allegations we've seen from YDC follow
up follow up thank you um and thank you
for the answer um are there currently to
the to the best of your knowledge any
people that are in prison that were in
YDC and they're filing lawsuits right
now yes many of the YDC the plaintiffs
in the YDC cases are individuals who are
currently incarcerated I don't have the
exact number but there there we do have
the we do have a fair amount that would
be a good number to know for us thank
you okay representative mens then
representative W thank you and thank you
again for taking my question um last
week the Chief Justice was with us and
he was saying um you know I'm not going
to quote him exactly but that basically
the impact of YDC is having a um an
impact on the ability of the state to
administer Justice more broadly um and
the clear message that I took away was
that the the YDC cases are putting an
incredible amount of stress on the
judicial branch are you feeling that
stress as well in term you know as the
as the The Entity that has to litigate
these things and is that going to mean
is that going to require you to need
additional resources going
forward yeah it's look the YDC cases
collectively are certainly a lot of work
there there are three components of it
right now one is the civil litigation so
so the civil lawsuits one is the the YDC
settlement fund and one component are
are the criminal cases and I think it is
putting a large burden certainly on the
Attorney General's office and and the
defense bar um I would tend to submit
that I think the burden is far greater
on those litigating the cases than than
Jud than the judicial branch not to say
there isn't a burden on the judicial
branch but I I think think it's a much
bigger workload on on those who are
litigating the the cases um and we are
going to need to continue to have
resources to do that I think we have
done a pretty good job resourcing up to
handle it though so I don't think we're
going to need to see an increase in
resources from what we have today but I
think if the civil litigation were to
continue it's been costing us probably
$3 to5 million a year to litigate the
civil
cases and it
is cost us you know
probably $1 to2 million a year to
prosecute the criminal CA to investigate
and prosecute the criminal cases and
then the settlement fund the
administrative expenses per year for the
Attorney General's office have probably
been somewhere between $1 and $3 million
a year so I don't expect that to go up
from here I guess that's to the extent
that there is
um positive news on the resource front I
don't expect that resource burden to go
up I actually expect that it would
continue to gradually
decline as these cases continue to
proceed because we the longer we do them
the more efficiencies we develop the
more familiar we are with the entire
universe of of the cases but but I think
that we we have been able to Resource up
to handle handle the workload but it is
it is a very big um resource
commitment but I think we have peaked at
when it comes to the resource commitment
of handling the cases right not
necessarily and I know we're going to
talk you're going to want to talk about
this in the payouts from a from a
settlement fund but certainly in the
resource commitment to handle the cases
I think I think we have peaked but it
it's a big resource burden for the
criminal justice system for the Civil
litigators you know for the
administrative function of the
settlement funds certainly for the
judicial branch absolutely it's a big
resource burden across across the
Spectrum but we are continuing to handle
our other cases too and I expect that we
will continue to be able to do that and
to do it well representative
W thank you Mr chairman thank you
General Fela this has been a real budget
Buster this YDC when you originally came
to us you said 100 million we gas
and you had done some research to come
up with that figure this last thing we
heard a few months ago was 500 million
course we've limited it to 75 million a
year and so it's going to stretch out
forever but some of the people are
saying the reason there's so many is
these lawyers are out advertising and
encouraging people and some of them are
making up stories and that has to be all
sorted out and what we we could set a
limit but we would appreciate if you
would set a limit lower than 33 and A3
or whatever ever it was per case per
lawyer because if he's got a 100
clients he's certainly not going to put
in the same effort after the first five
or six as he's going to do for the rest
so you should have kind of declining
percentage that the lawyer getting
otherwise they're they'll thinking this
is the getrich quick scheme oh I can
advertise I get all these people to get
up and and whatever they get I get a
third and it it's it's really disturbing
to me that you know this is plus this is
kind of a
trauma
situation and it seems like in other
cases like this where trauma is a is a
big part of it that not only should
there
be a cash award but there should be a
compulsory counseling psychiatric
counseling and if if you refuse to take
the counseling you don't get the money
we're trying to help you if the whole
purpose of this is to help the people
that have been wronged then a big part
of it would be psychiatric counseling
and set some number of hours to it and
no I don't want it I just want the money
then you don't get the money you have to
go submit to the psychiatric counseling
if we're really in the business
of helping people that have been wronged
that's a big part of it because a lot of
this is in their mind and it has SL you
know obviously that it's made a mess of
their minds with what's happened to them
so I think I'm surprised that none of
the other cases that went across the
country like this have included
compulsory counseling and I think it
would be in I would suggest those things
plus reducing the percentage the lawyer
gets would mean fewer cases especially
when they're out soliciting for all of
them but that's my thought that when I
thought about all this in the way it was
described as trauma inforced and so on
that that's the way you help people you
have some psychi counseling to try to
get them to you know realize what's
happened and and how to adjust to it and
you know some of them have done it on
their own but obviously the rest have
not so I would hope you would bring some
of that into the the whole mix and see
what the the effect would be plus reduce
the amount that's going to somebody with
multiple cases 33 and a third in every
case after a while it's cookie cutter
yeah that's similar to to a question I
asked you right about that uh
attorney's fees aspect can you want to
talk about that sure no I app I
appreciate the question representative I
did just want to say one thing just to
make it clear for for the record I know
there's been a lot of discussion about
the you know we've had a lot of
discussion about those YDC settman fund
over the last few
years I've always maintained that that
it is very hard to know what the total
amount is going to be and we have to
continue to sort of evaluate that as as
we go right we started with 100 million
a few years ago we didn't know how many
claims we're going to get and we also
don't know what to think of the claims
until we get them and so I think we have
to I think the approach we we've always
had to take with this we need to
continue to take is we just have to
continue to
re-evaluate as we continue to get more
information right and as we continue to
see these
claims and we don't want to think about
these claims as a you know 1,400 15
00 monolith 1400 1500 claim monolith
every claim is different all these
claims are individual claims and you
know we we've resolved 250 of them we're
going to continue to review the claims
as they come and claims will continue to
be resolved but we're also going to
continue to re-evaluate as we see the
claims come through and we will continue
to provide information of course to the
legislature to to the governor to
everyone in involved as we see these
claims coming through and decisions will
need to be made based on the information
that we continue to receive so I think
you know I said it a few years ago it
would would be hard to know the total I
would say that today we know what we've
spent to date it's very hard to estimate
what we might spend long term as for
attorney's
fees I agree that it's something that
needs to continue to be SC scrutinized
right we had this conversation when we
were first looking at the legislation
back in
2022 whether to set a you know an amount
that or I should say where to set the
maximum amount and the 33 and a half% at
the end of the day is a maximum that
does that is never me was never meant to
say that every case that's what the
attorney fee should be right and we
talked about who would make that
decision and
ultimately the decision was made to
leave that to the to the discretion of
the administrator but like I say with
this entire process the plaintiffs have
always said they'll continue to
reevaluate how they think it's going we
need to re continue to reevaluate how we
think it's going
and always continue to to look at every
part of it and I think you know it's a
question that needs to be asked to the
administrator if too often 33 and a
half% is being given and it's a question
that would have to be asked of us if in
the claims we resolve are we always
agreeing 33 and a half% and I completely
agree that the longer you go the harder
it is to justify a high attorney fee
because there might be a lot of work you
put in in the earlier claims because
it's all new and and you haven't gone
through it before the more claims you do
I think it's safe to say probably the
less work you're putting into each claim
and so it's just another piece of this
we have to continue to re-evaluate but I
would I would agree that that that that
is something that needs to continue to
be scrutinized and something we need to
keep a close eye on because the goal of
this
fund is to compensate those who have
suffered harm right not to pay lawyers
or or or send money to other places
representative followup I think it's
it's progress that because of the way
we're limited it to 75 million a year
there won't be as many huge payoffs that
people go out and just wait
they're not going to use it to to help
themselves which is what it's supposed
to do they're just going to go below it
and uh you know and and they'll have
their friends lined up to grab a piece
and all this kind of thing so having a
little counseling might tell them okay
this money is supposed to make you heal
first we're going to have compulsory
counseling then you're going to have
some more guidance on what you do what
you missed out on by going through all
this and and now we want to F give you
some guidance on how you can mend your
life instead of just woo going to Vegas
you know one of the things the
administrator's office has done is tried
to do what they can to connect people
with those types of resources so that
that's that's a function that I think
the administrator's office is well
positioned to play because they're seen
as the neutrals in this you know the
Attorney General's office we have to
litigate on behalf of the state so I
think a victim or a plaintiff is not
necessarily going to be coming to us to
ask about those resources but we've
we've had those discussions with the
administrator and they're trying to do
what they can to connect victims with
those types of resources like counseling
all right representative eil followed by
representative cell okay just uh quickly
so just based on the numbers that you
gave you said three to five million a
year for criminal for YDC sorry 1 to2
million for civil and 1 to three million
a year for administration of the claims
so I was just trying to estimate so it's
like5 to10 million a year that um is
being used through the Department of
Justice to handle the YDC
claims yeah I think it was I think it
was 3 to five million for civil civil I
got it flipped yeah okay one to two for
criminal okay I got it flipped and then
one to three for the settlement fund but
the toal I think the total comes out
five to 10 okay yes so that you add it
all up so that was one thing so the
other thing we talked about with the
judicial branch is is the fact it
sounded like everyone is filing claims
through the superior court but they also
can file claims through the claims
process so the idea is that if you if
you mediate and settle through the
claims process that cuts off your Venue
to the Superior Court correct is that
yes right and conversely if you get a
settlement through the Superior Court
you can't go back to the claims I think
for some of us it was a little we didn't
realize you could file in both places
yes you can file in both places if you
if you have filed a lawsuit in Superior
Court and you file then you then file a
claim in the claims fund you're required
to stay your Superior Court litigation
while you're in the claims fund so there
may be a lawsuit sitting there in
Superior Court and you may also be in
the claims fund you're not allowed to
move the two forward at the same time I
think what the court and I don't want to
speak for the courts because I I'm I'm
not I I'm not part of the the judicial
branch and I don't you know have to deal
with with their their administrative
functions but there are a lot of
administrative uh tasks there's a lot of
administrative work that comes with just
managing that many cases you know you
when you file a simple pleading if
you're filing it in a docket that's got
a bunch of individual cases you got to
file that same thing over and over again
you know so organizing it certainly
takes a lot of work there's a lot of
work and resource burden that that comes
with that because of the sheer number of
cases but the cases are not going to be
able to move forward at the same time so
you're not going to be having say a
resolution proceeding in the settlement
fund and then a trial in your civil case
shortly after that's just it's not going
to happen that way because if you're in
the claims fund your civil case has to
pause do do you do you have a sense of
how many claims have been filed through
the claims process it is approaching 900
it's getting close to 900 so a lot of
claims are coming into the claims fund
at this process at this point I think uh
somewhere between 14 and
1400 and
1500 civil cases in superior court have
been filed it was 1363 or something
representative C thank you Mr chair so I
understand fully that we cannot put a
number a figure on the number of dollars
that this is going to cost ultimately
but I asked this question two years ago
I'm wondering we should be able to put
bounds around what are the potential
number of people that are going to file
and that that number would be anybody
that ever went to the through the YDC
system so at this stage of the game do
we know what that number is you know
we've been at it now for a few years I
would expect that we would have the
records to know how many people went
through there so what that would be your
ultimate number of potential lawsuits do
number I'm I'm sure we could we could
get that number right I don't have that
number here but but the total number of
individuals who have gone through YDC
you know in a within a certain time
window we could certainly get that
number yes well that would be important
because at least that would give us one
bound that we could work with and say
okay well at least now we know this is
the the most damage that can be done Y
and then we can work backwards from
there to to then longterm figure out
what it might cost us financially yep so
because again if not this is totally
open-ended and it's you know I'll be
running you know 20 years from now the
for the seat and we'll still be dealing
with the same issue you know and I'll be
asking the same question so
representative R thank you Mr chair so
still on the YDC uh claims so the the
the lawyer fees so let me get let me
back up so let's say this the the state
says okay we've accepted your claim we
are going to settle it does the lawyer
fee come off that amount amount or is
the lawyer fee paid in addition to that
amount my thought is that I mean if we
leave the free the fee up to the free
market there may be attorneys that say
I'll take your case for 20% or
15% yeah and and we do leave the fee I
would say up to the market because the
33 and a half% is just a maximum
somebody can get okay it it's and so
there's nothing that stops the attorney
from making a deal with their client say
when they first enter the fund
that I'm going to get 20% right of
whatever is recovered through this
settlement fund process there's nothing
that stops them from from doing that the
33 and a half% is just a cap but it
comes out of what the award is so if a
claimant comes through and gets
$500,000 and they've agreed and there's
a either the administrator Awards 20% in
attorney's fees or they've read there's
going to be a 20% attorney fee that
comes out of the 500,000 so the state
doesn't pay more than
$500,000 in that instance the claim it
would get 400,000 the attorney would get
100,000 okay follow Mr chair and
following up on representative wier's
question has there ever been a
settlement that the state H is aware of
where part of that would be for the
victim to get counseling or therapy I
mean even if someone was physically
injured and sued the state um has the
state made it the the settlement
contingent on whether they get physical
therapy for instance or occupational
therapy for their
injury I am not aware of of that type of
settlement especially in a in a case in
a in cases like this okay thank you no
representa
Ms um if we're if we're done with YDC
for a minute I'd like to go into a
different direction oh all right well
well let's wait wait for for a moment on
that okay
um so when we first SP when we spoke
about this two years ago you told us
that um there's something called
sovereign immunity which lets us decide
exactly what turn under what terms and
the state can be sued yep um so we still
think that is that yes that's absolutely
the case
and and are we have we by setting up the
the the settlement system the way we
have
already
um sort of put us in in a contract kind
of situation where those terms are no
longer changeable no I don't believe
that to be the case I I don't think the
state is locked into
any any terms of this of the settlement
fund for anyone who hasn't received an
award right so if they're already paid
they're already paid right so right or
if an award has already been made oh I
see and and we're paying on the
installment plan correct right like if
the legislature has authorized an award
to be made and it gets made before the
legislature
changes the way the fund works I think
we're locked into that but the
legislature retains the ability to to
make changes absolutely and would it be
in any way improper for this committee
to talk to the people running the
settlement fund
and the same way we're talking to you I
don't think it's improper to to do that
no to talk about these kind of details
and yeah I don't think it would be
improper I I think the one thing you'd
want to avoid and I just say this is the
lawyer for the state and in many
contexts sometimes a lawyer for
legislators is that I wouldn't ask the
administrator about specific cases and
how he has decided a particular case but
I think it's perfectly fair to ask the
administr about how overall the fund is
being administered I think that's that's
perfectly Fair topic of conversation and
you can always ask the questions and I
think the administrator will know how to
defer if he thinks he shouldn't comment
because he's an experienced attorney
experienced attorney and a former Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court so he knows
how to not answer the questions he
thinks he shouldn't answer all right and
one last thing you said that um
the the victim and his attorney can
agree to various terms so can they agree
in the other direction to say I'll give
you 50% of of what uh whatever is
collected you know or or are we somehow
enforcing that by we write the check to
the attorney and we write the check to
the victim or something like that yeah I
mean we we we write the checks the way
we write the checks at the end of the
day and so the way we can enforce it is
to say you're you know the award for the
attorney is going to be this here here
is what the attorney
gets
look all of us are free as individuals
to enter into contracts under terms that
we
decide are best for us or that we are
willing to agree to We Can't Stop a
claimant from agreeing to give an
attorney more than we have said will
award the attorney out of the settlement
fund we We Can't Stop a claimant from
doing that just like we can't stop
anyone else from their freedom to enter
into
contracts my sense is that's not going
to happen that often but look we we
can't enforce that it just isn't our
role as the government to get into that
right so we're more or less saying this
is what we'll pay for this kind of a
case right that you know we award
$100,000 a victim and and the $30,000
for attorney there's 130,000 and then
it's up to you guys how you split it
sort of I guess um uh I mean I guess
we've read some some news articles about
um that make things sound not so good in
the sense that um some attorney loaned
his client money and then decided to
drop the client and now they have the
own kind of case and things like that
right I mean yeah I I would just say a
couple things on that a first is a
caution I I think that in a in a in a
situation like this that is as
complicated as it is and involves as
many claimants as it does and as many
different law firms and as many
different
lawyers you're always going to have some
situations that don't go well um you
also
I I think cannot always rely on what
makes it into you know a news article as
being an accurate depiction of of what's
happening between a a claimant and their
attorney um
but I you know we we just we're not
going to be able to prevent every
negative
situation with something like this but
we need to do the best we can to
minimize that so that we're if we're
going to do this and as a state we're
going to continue to have this process
exist which is ultimately up
to the elected policy makers the
legislature and the governor we want to
make sure that it's fulfilling its
intended purpose which is to provide
compensation to victims and not
to be a uh you know a lawyer Employment
Act Right so we need we're but
Perfection I think will elude Us in any
Endeavor that we undertake this one
included but we want to get as close to
Perfection as we possibly
can all right representative W so we
heard of a case it was in the paper
where somebody went to the lawyer to go
to court they saw how slow it was going
so they went to the alternative
resolution and they got an award then
the lawyer sued them 25% of the award
which he hadn't done anything to get
what happened with that case I don't
know you know I I I don't know if if it
was if it was the lawyer I'm not sure it
was the lawyer suing the claim in it
might have been the you know the old
lawyer suing the claimant's new lawyer
right so claimant first had a
lawsuit with one attorney they decided
to go through the settlement fund with a
different attorney got an award and then
their old attorney sued the new attorney
I think that might be what happened I
don't know if that has been resolved you
I'm not sure what's going to happen the
state's not a party to that lawsuit
we're obviously going to pay attention
you know we we want we want to do what
we can to protect the interest of of
victims and and the claimants in this
process but I'm I don't think that's
actually it's been resolved and if it's
been settled out of court we wouldn't
know we wouldn't know what the result
lawyers a bad name
if as a lawyer I'm used to you know
people saying things like I hate lawyers
right so I think most people who aren't
lawyers don't like lawyers and those of
us who are lawyers have learned to live
with that and and we did hear from the
Judiciary that there are many cases
between victims and people other than
the state right so maybe contractors or
other people that worked in the YDC area
right and true so so they're getting a
burden with cases that are completely
separate from what we're paying victims
right so yeah yes that's true I I will
say that a lot of the cases that
involve parties other than the state
still have the state in them so e even
if there are cases against contractors
often the state has still also been sued
in those cases for negligent supervision
of the contractor because the state is
the one who contracts with that with
that entity so it's uh we've been looped
into most of this and but when somebody
settles through the settlement process
presumably they sign a paper saying
we're no longer going to claim against
the state in these side kind of
situations right the settlement is all a
settlement of all
claims the settle the something like
that if you resolve through the
settlement fund process you're only
resolving CLA claims that you can be
compensated for by the settlement fund
process so you know there are a few
tangential claims that can hang out
there even after you go through the
settlement fund process I think the
reality is that even if those claims
still exist they're not going to be
claims that you're going to be able to
recover very much if anything on against
the state at least so while they may not
technically be released and extinguished
they not claims were going to be too
worried about about uh as far as being
high exposure claims all right all right
let's move on from YDC and with
representative months thank you Mr
chairman um I I'm not I'm not a lawyer
um and I've I've never worked in law
enforcement um and I I I I offer that
because um I'm going to ask a question
about another topic area that's um shall
we say been in the news quite a bit
lately and I'm I'm not trying to play
gotcha I just I'm trying to understand
exactly what the lay of the land is
um are there any guidelines that the
Department of Justice has issued to
local law enforcement on how they should
um enforce immigration
laws uh and if there are no guidelines
will guidelines be sent to them to
provide some some Direction
there are no guidelines we've issued
recently and I haven't made any
determination at this point as to
whether we'll be issuing any any
guidance yet I so I no recent guidance
whether there's guidance from many years
past that would probably be obsolete now
anyway I I don't know that for sure and
we haven't made any determination at
this point whether we'd be issuing any
guidance I don't have any plans in the
near future to do that is there is there
um is there precedent for doing that um
you know providing some kind of
guideline that would apply Statewide yes
we do we do issue guidance to law
enforcement on various topics we'll
sometimes issue memos to law enforcement
directing them to operate a certain way
cases all right thank you um so let's um
let's move on to just general budget
type of things so we have a piece of
paper here which shows us the whole
state budget of comparing um fiscal year
19 to fiscal year 25 for General funds
and your your department has the
distinction of having the greatest
increase of General funds of anything on
this piece of paper of
104% right so you used in fiscal year 19
uh 10.9 million of General funds and in
fiscal year 25
22.2 million of General funds so that's
a that's a huge increase and looking at
this paper that you gave us of the new
positions it sort of makes it obvious
where where this money is going to right
because there's pages and pages of new
positions so why is so so can we justify
why things are so different today than
they were only six years
ago yeah so I'll take I think there's a
couple of different points to make on
that the first is
increase is not all of it and in fact I
wouldn't even say the majority of it is
salary and benefits for new positions so
I think over a big chunk of it about 5
$2 million are just grants general fund
grants that we just give out to to
others so to the child advocacy centers
to the internet crimes against children
task force to to local departments on
the drug task force and and human
trafficking grants so about $5.2 million
of that based on the numbers that I've
got here can we get a a sheet
specifically about that yes we will we
will we will get you that um so about
$5.2 million of that is not related to
the operations of the
department and then another roughly
million dollars is rent to das so our
rent has gone up like the rent we pay
given the our move right our move from
our old building to a new building had
to do a lot of renovations to that space
it was built into the lease so that's
another million dollars of that general
fund increase so I think that's a that's
a first important point to note is that
a lot of that is
not salary and benefits for positions um
and then a lot of the general fund
increase so there are new positions but
a lot of the general fund increase even
associated with all of our positions are
just raises salary raises so there was
obviously in the last bium the Big 12
you know 12% raise across across the
board so we have
received quite a few new positions in
The Last 5 Years I don't know how this
compares to other departments throughout
the state I just I don't I don't have a
sense of that I can talk a little bit
about where these tell you from the ones
we've been seeing you know there might
be two here or three there that kind of
thing but this looks like 30 or
something you know what I mean it's a
lot yep no it's certainly a lot I I mean
the 10 of those are
the assistant Deputy medical examiners
who are now we did this in the last BM
we now have full-time employees where
they used to be contractors so they're
not really new people they're they're
new positions but they're there it's
actually less people now working with
the Department we used to have 20-some
contractors we now just have 10
full-time salaried employees and that
actually did not result in a cost
increase to the office office so that's
positions
[Music]
we we
added some and I think this will be a
conversation that we should probably
have again in our budget presentation
because I will say I expect some of
these positions are going to be unfunded
I don't want to get out in front of the
governor like I want to let her present
her budget but I think some of these
positions are going to be unfunded so
the list we you have today
it's going to look a little
different when we're back before you
when the governor has submitted her
budget sure and is this list as salaries
benefit that would be a Kathy question
so I just put the salaries on there yes
all right at this time but I can get you
a more comprehensive if you need it
great yeah did I see representative
Lehman's
hand yeah thank you Mr chair I just
think In fairness uh over the last
several years or terms uh we as a
legislature have asked the Attorney
General to bring in like an elderly
Fraud Unit which we supported more staff
and uh so we've been part of that
increased supportive of his budget going
up so they could hire additional lawyers
to take care of the fraud and especially
the elderly abuse that we talked about
last term right yeah the new so I was
going to I'm perf Al willing to take all
the blame or you know whatever you know
as you move that elderly side of the
table yeah yeah yeah I I understand no
I'm not saying he's doing anything
illegal or anything you know what I mean
it's just it's just that now that we're
looking under the couch cushions for
loose change you know we we got to go
the to the places that have had the most
increase I mean that's all it is okay
anyways go Ahad yeah no and and we could
certainly continue to walk through it so
there's that there's the elder abuse
Financial exploitation unit the data
privacy unit which was created as part
of the State's new data Privacy Law
we've added resources to the election
law unit to try to beef up our election
law enforcement we added a new public
Integrity unit that's a new unit in the
last five years that was four new
lawyers a few new staff so there are
there are new functions that have been
added to the office that have accounted
for a lot of these new
positions and we have also we've added a
couple of new civil litigator
positions we've added a couple of new
we've added you know some new attorney
positions in various bureaus at the end
of the
day the work that the Department of
Justice does is we sort of just have to
do the work that that comes in and if we
don't have the people to do the work we
have to hire outside Council to do it so
our I would actually submit that our
biggest CH
our our biggest goal when it comes to
efficiencies is to be able to hand is to
have enough employees to handle the work
that we do need to do that really is
thrust upon us it's for the most part
not discretionary work as opposed to
having to hire outside counsel and the
the workload on the office when you
start to think of various cases that
we've been dealing with over the last 5
to six years has really increased pretty
significantly YDC being one of the major
cost drivers but the school funding
cases some other big class action cases
we're dealing with with with
HHS um trying to expand what we're doing
in the election law area but also
handling various civil lawsuits where
the state sued over over laws that we
pass you know the the workload has
increased so I I think that there are
efficiencies that we can find in the
office we've been going through that
process in the governor's budget and
we'll certainly be seeing some like I
said some positions will be unfunded and
I think it's something we have to
continue to to look carefully at but I
also think that when you walk through
the new positions we have and you look
at the general fund increase over the
last 5 to six
years a a lot of the new positions we
have are either the admes like I said
who were just converted from contractors
or new functions that the office has
been asked to do or tasked with doing or
they are directly related to a workload
that has increased because at the end of
the day we serve a a lot of our
functions to serve the rest of state
government so if the rest of state
government grows we're going to grow
because we serve state government but we
can certainly be prepared to walk
through that
in a more detailed fashion because I
know for this presentation you asked us
for the
list when we're back before you in a
couple weeks with the governor's budget
we'll have the the most upto-date list
of positions that are still not unfunded
that are new in the last five to six
years and we'll certainly be prepared to
walk through those and explain to you
why those exist and why we think we
should still have them and you of course
will have to decide whether we
should and it's not that you're total
funds are necessarily they're up a
little more than so the way we look at
this is there's been like 30% worth of
inflation and population growth over
this six-year period of time and your
total funds are up um let's see here
37% right so that's not you know it's a
little high but it's not outrageous it
but it's the general the mix has shifted
towards General funds
that's that's kind of the key thing and
I think that has a lot to do with grants
and rent frankly if you if you take the
grants and rent out of that okay you're
going to knock off a lot of that percent
increase thank you representative eel
and then representative R okay I have
couple questions so I I don't know if
you're prepared to do this today but um
we've been uh asking the agencies to
share with us specifically what's being
cut um you know because the governor has
asked people to cut by like 4% and I
mean I think it's helpful for us to
understand where those cuts are and what
the impacts of the of the cuts are so I
don't know whether you're prepared to do
that today or maybe more in detail it's
it's also
late yeah I I would request to defer on
that until our next presentation and and
and partly I could go through that with
you but I also I know based on the
discussions we're having with the
governor's
office I I am reluctant to get out in
front of her as as far as what the cuts
are going to be yeah so that's okay so
then the the other question is um so
have we gotten the money I'm I'm
thinking about your Environmental
Protection Bureau in particular have we
gotten the P
settlement money and are there other
huge lawsuits that we're involved in
that might have large payouts in the way
that the past that's my two questions I
don't believe we have received the first
trunch of the money yet it'll be fairly
soon I can get you a a better estimate
on that it's not in yet it goes into the
trust fund I don't believe that money is
in
yet even the 65 million I think that's
what you're referring to that's only a a
portion of our of the total value of of
that case that only covers a portion of
the claims so we think there's still a
lot to do in the P cases with regard to
potential recovery uh we are involved we
have our social media cases so our
social media investigations some of our
lawsuits hopeful that eventually those
will lead not only to significant
changes in that with how those companies
operate but also some Financial
recoveries uh we have our we still have
some opioid litigation ongoing which
will lead to more recoveries those those
are some of the big cases but we're
we're involved in a lot of different
Multistate cases so Attorneys General
will work with AGS around the country
especially in the consumer protection
space on multi-state cases that that
that bring in recoveries so there are a
number of cases we're involved in that
we expect will get money in for p cases
being a big part of that and the 65
million is not the end of the recovery
in those cases we expect to get
significantly more but that's going to
play out in the coming years well I ask
because I know from the from past
experience that some of those
settlements go into the general fund and
we end up being able to use them for
things yep yeah every time I do my
budget presentation whether it's the
governor or the legislature the in the
actual sort of budget presentation I
always have a a page that shows you the
money we bring in and I and I yes and
it's always far more than the but I
assume it's hard to predict so all right
representative run thank you uh Mr chair
I don't know I apologize if you answered
this already and I'm a newbie to this
committee but other funds what are some
of those other
funds can you answer that yes so we
receive uh like our charitable Trust
unit they're 100% funded from um fees oh
um that because they work with the
nonprofits and um trustees charitable
trustees uh the administr uh the admes
the assistant Deputy medical examiners
they're all paid for they're 100%
self-funded from um payments that they
receive from funeral homes for uh death
certificates and cremation views they
have to view everybody um and certify
everybody before it's cremated kind and
um and counties for death investigations
so counties reimburse for death
investigations so those are probably our
most major other funds that we receive
okay thank you and then uh one other
question I noticed there's a
position um that was transferred from De
a legal assist ENT and then um there's a
an attorney an environmental attorney um
that was filled that's half well 44%
general fund 56% other and it it brings
to mind the fact that does dees they
staff attorneys as well right so what's
the the how is this this position
distinguished from um attorneys that are
within Dees
so Dees like other agencies does have a
few lawyers in the agency but they'll do
things like help the agency write
rules um stuff like that they don't they
don't represent the agency in court
bring enforcement
actions okay do things like that so that
that's what distinguishes a doj lawyer
from from a Dees lawyer um I I think the
I'm not sure which position you're
referring to that as a a funding
breakdown of some general funds some
other funds but we do have a few
positions in the office where an agency
like the Department of
Insurance who is not General funded
they're funded by the various
assessments on on that they um assess I
don't like the word use of the word
impose but I guess it's imposed impose
assessments on on companies they're
that's the way they're
funded they they fund at least part of a
position in the office there's a couple
agencies to do that where the position
actually exists in doj it works for doj
but they do the they much of the work
they do is to assist the department of
insurance or whatever other agency so
that agency pays for part or all of a
position so we have a couple of
arrangements like that and that I'm not
sure exactly what position that is but
it might yeah it was a new position in
2024 okay is it an environmental
yeah it's the new en attorney that we
got
in24 yeah and so
it's Bureau that whole Bureau is
funded 44% General funds
56% I call it other but it's transfers
from by Environmental Services okay all
right thank you all right representative
eel followed by representative wer okay
let's see how I can ask this question
you're a lawyer so you can handle it
however um with respect to the uh
president's executive order uh ter or
halting the payment of federal funds for
various programs I know that it has now
been temporarily enjoined I know that
the governor has expressed concern about
it it seems to me that as a state if we
have these federal funds that we have
gone out and entered into contracts in
Reliance on receipt of those funds if we
are in those contracts and
can't fulfill our side which means pay
for
them might the state not be liable for
contract
violations you can answer that or not
yeah well I'm going to keep it pretty
General and you know I'm always always
going to be pretty uh circumspect about
commenting on the state's potential
liability in any situation but you know
every Grant is different I'll say that
most Grant pretty much every Grant
agreement though we're going to enter
into with someone that involves federal
funds is going to have a term that makes
the continued receipt the state's
continued receipt of the federal funds
or or I should say it's going to have a
term that makes the agreement contingent
on the state's continued receipt of the
federal funds right so
generally at a high level and and
looking at it generally I don't I don't
have a big concern about the state being
liable to a grantee out there if if
we're no longer receiving federal funds
to to fund the grant so that that
doesn't concern me um as to
whether you know there are there our
claims we would have against the federal
government in a specific situation where
funding is cut off that's just going to
depend on the particular Circumstance
the way federal grants work and Kathy
knows a lot more about this than I do so
if I say something wrong I'll let her
kick me and correct me but yeah the the
way federal grants work is they often
stay open for multiple fiscal years so
you know it could be three four five
years so a grant that was awarded two or
three years
ago and the award's been made it can
continue to be draw drawn down down
sometimes for several years and those
might be different than new grants that
haven't been awarded yet right so when
we think about a federal funding
pause you know it's easy to think about
it as as just one single concept but it
really it what that means can differ
depending on the Grant and what federal
fiscal year we're talking about from
that Grant right so are we saying no
more Awards will be made under this
grant or are we saying you can't draw
down even money from fiscal years where
it's already been awarded and what the
legal implications of that are might
vary a little bit Grant by Grant so
we're you didn't really ask this
question but I'll but I will at least
assure you that at the doj we're working
with all of our various agencies on to
assess what the potential impact could
be of of a pause or eventual
discontinuation of of the various
sources of federal funds that we get but
it's early days and I think it would be
a mistake to jump to conclusions because
while the original o andb memo said that
all federal funds were going to be
paused that was rescinded pretty quickly
the White House put out guidance pretty
quickly saying the pause is not even
really going to apply to Grants outside
of those implicated by the president's
executive orders and even those are are
fairly narrow in the grand scheme of
things we're still working to assess and
get our arms around it but I don't
they're they're a somewhat narrow slice
of the overall Universe of federal funds
Kathy is there anything that I said
that's incredibly wrong that you need to
correct kick you at all I mean I'll just
say I I feel better knowing that you're
work you know not that you wouldn't but
yeah it's a concerning situation yeah
we've been we've been thinking a lot
about this and working a lot on this
since the day that this all started
which is only a little over a week ago
which is amazing to think it hasn't been
that long but we're we're working hard
on it and everybody's working hard on it
all right representative wer for the
last question thank you just a couple of
quick ones you mentioned that your
responsible to passing out grants to
these some newly created organizations I
would like to see the list because we
may decide they're not worth the money
that you're passing out and the the
second
question
these education funding things go on
forever and you have to
keep um defending them I am always
surprised that you never bring in any
legislators as expert Witnesses who have
worked for years and know all the
iterations of all these things and could
provide expert Witnesses and
the Attorney General doesn't seem to
know well I don't think it's I think
we're going to know better than to lose
the case I think we would add to the
case when the other we know what the
other side is going to say and we could
have a little preparation but you you're
overlooking expert Witnesses in this
legislature all the time to a defend a
case that I think we could help you with
can I add to that that maybe when does
our Supreme Court work like the US
Supreme Court in the sense that there
aren't Witnesses when you take a a case
to the Supreme Court no you you don't
have witnesses on on appeal yes it's
just questions of law y but I think we
could help you prepare the case and we
haven't been asked much to do that but
anyway thank you appreciate your coming
absolutely thank you all we'll see you
weeks for the committee we'll see you
tomorrow if anybody is speaking at the
well I hope they speak briefly because
coming no bills for us no but somebody
could be arguing something you know on
some other bill on I am not no no okay
and and um I think after that we have
the governor's address the following
Thursday but I don't think this
committee has any schedule next week I
believe but I could be wrong
Tuesday
Tuesday yes and a non- gerain amendment
to something it starts at
one oh the full finances meeting next
week okay very good Tuesday okay thank
you